Thank you.
Thank
you.
So I've been thinking about things that
I'm happy about and what I'm most happy
about so far is that I haven't spilled
my,
my bubbly water into my computer so far
while I've been doing these lectures,
so that's always.
I'll probably do it tonight now that I'm
bragging about having avoided it.
So,
uh,
thank you all for coming.
This is the last lecture in this 12 part
series.
I did mention that I have made
arrangements with the theater at least
to do this once a month for the next
four months and we'll see.
We'll play it by year past then I want
to continue and I'll find another venue
and perhaps to do it every two weeks,
but certainly once a month and maybe I
can even get deeper into the material if
it's only once a month.
So that would be then when then will
really slow down to a snail's crawl.
So this is a tough one tonight.
You know,
it's something,
a story that everyone with any sense
should approach with a substantial
degree of trepidation.
I've been working on my book this week
on Chapter Seven,
which is called do what is meaningful,
not what's expedient,
and it's really,
it's been a very difficult chapter
because I'm coming to it,
I'm trying to extend my understanding of
sacrifice,
which is of course what we're going to
talk about tonight in great detail.
Um,
and,
and I've been wrestling with exactly how
to do that.
And I'm going to read you some of that.
I think today I don't generally read
when I do my lectures,
but this is so complicated that I'm not
confident of my ability to just spin it
off,
you know,
sort of,
um,
what would you call it?
A spontaneously,
that's the word.
And so andy last give me a chance to
test out whether what I've written,
which I've been struggling with has the
kind of poetic flow that I'd like to
have.
If you're writing,
it's really good to read things aloud,
you know,
because you can tell if you've got the
rhythmic cadence right then.
So,
so anyways,
thank you all for coming.
Many of you have,
I believe,
attended all 12 lectures and that's
really remarkable.
It's amazing that,
you know,
this place has been full every single
lecture rights completely unbelievable.
That would be the case.
And you know,
about more than 2 million views of this
has been watched more than 2 million
views.
It's not 2 million people because it
would be the same people I would suspect
many times,
but that's also crazy,
but it's a crazy world and it seems to
be getting crazier.
So hopefully this is some addition to
stabilizing it and making slightly more
sane.
That's the hope.
Anyways,
so we've got a couple of stories to deal
with tonight.
Um,
complex,
complex stories.
I'm not really easy to comprehend in any
sense of the sense of the word.
I mean with the story of Isaiah.
God calls on his,
his,
his chosen individual,
Abraham,
the person who's made this contract with
to sacrifice his son.
And it's in.
How in the world are you supposed to
make sensible,
any sort of sensible fence out of that.
It's exactly that sort of story that
makes modern people who are convinced
that the faster we put the biblical
stories behind this,
the better.
It's grist for the mill.
You know,
because it seems like such a
incomprehensible and even barbaric act
on the part of God and so you know,
I,
I hesitate to even approach it because,
well,
because there's so many ways that the
interpretation of that sort can go
wrong,
but we'll see how it goes.
And so let's walk through it and see
what happens.
So we're gonna Start with a story of
Sarah and Isaac,
and the Lord visited Sarah as he had
said.
You remember when Abraham was in the
midst of his appropriate sacrificial
routines,
which we've characterized as his return
to the contract he made with the idea of
the good,
the contract with God.
He was informed by God that he would get
what he most wanted,
which was an error.
And he,
despite his advanced old age,
and of course Sarah was very skeptical
about that as she had every reason to
be.
But this story opens with the
fulfillment of God's promise to Abraham.
And the Lord visited Sarah as he had
said,
and the Lord Did unto Sarah as he had
spoken for Sarah conceived and bore
Abraham a son in his old age.
At the set time of which God had spoken
to him,
and Abraham called the name of his son
that was born unto him whom Sarah
Barrett to him,
Isaac and Abraham circumcised his son,
Isaac being eight days old as God
commanded him,
had commanded him,
and Abraham was 100 years old when his
son Isaac was born unto him and Sarah
said,
garth had made God.
Had God have made me laugh so that all
that here will laugh with me.
And she said,
who would've said unto Abraham that
Sarah should have given children's suck
for?
I have born him a son in his old age and
the child grew and was weaned and
Abraham made a great feast the same day
that Isaac was weaned.
I suppose one of the,
one of the purposes,
let's say perhaps the literary purposes
of this story is to exaggerate for
dramatic purposes the importance of a
child.
You know,
when people are young,
and I think this is particularly true in
the modern world,
they seem to often regard the,
the possibility of having a child as an
impediment to their lifestyle.
You know,
and of course in some ways I suppose
that's true,
although you have to have quite a
lifestyle before a child actually
constitutes an impediment because having
a child in your life is actually
something that's remarkable almost
beyond belief.
You know,
you can have a relationship with a child
that is better than any relationship
you've ever had with anyone in your
life.
If you're careful and if you're
fortunate,
fortunate.
Being fortunate helps,
you know,
I've seen many people delay having
children and for understandable reasons.
It's no simple decision to have a child
and of course now we can make the
decision to have a child,
which of course people couldn't in in
past ages really.
But sometimes you see people delay and
they delay too long and then they don't
get to have a child and then they're
desperate and you know,
they spent a decade doing fertility
treatments or that sort of thing and
immersing themselves in one
disappointment after another.
And it's just at that point what you see
exactly how catastrophic it is.
It can be how catastrophic it can be for
people not to have one of the.
Not to be able to undergo one of the
great adventures of life,
let's say,
and one of the things this story does by
by delaying the arrival of Isaac and
delaying the arrival of Isaac
continually is to exaggerate the the
important significance of the child
because it isn't until you're deprived
of something,
it's truly not until you're deprived of
something that you have any sense of
what its value is,
and Isaac was waiting,
or Abraham was waiting a very long time,
100 years,
a very long time,
and the same with Sarah,
and so they're unbelievably excited and
of course this also heightens the drama
that's inherent in the entire
sacrificial story because it's not only
that eventually that Abraham is called
upon to sacrifice Isaac,
which would be bad enough under any
other,
any circumstances whatsoever,
self-evidently,
but the fact that he's been waiting a
century for the arrival of this child
desperately and made all the proper
sacrifices and lived in the appropriate
manner to allow this to occur.
Der dramatically heightens the,
the,
the literary tension.
Now you remember Hagar,
this is the next part of the story Hagar
was,
is,
was Sarah's handmade,
and when Sarah was unable to bear
Abraham a child,
she sent him,
Hagar and Hagar immediately got pregnant
and gave birth to Ishmael.
And,
uh,
the story picks up from that point here.
And this is quite interesting.
I mentioned the other week when I was
talking to you guys a couple of weeks in
a row.
Just how interesting it has been to
scour the Internet for the,
for the paintings that are associated
with these stories.
There's just,
uh,
there's an amazing wealth of great
paintings that illustrate every single
bit of the,
of every single biblical story.
And it's,
it's,
uh,
it's really been enlightening to me to
find out just exactly how poorly
educated I am.
You know,
like I,
I'm an,
I'm a what would say I'm a,
I'm a great admirer of,
of artistic talent and of artistic
endeavor,
but there's so much I don't know about
the history of art,
that it's just absolutely beyond belief.
And to see this treasure trove of images
that I really had no idea that existed.
Of course,
they're spread all over the world and
it's only been in recent years that you
could have access to them in this way.
It's just a.
it's a,
it's a constant revelation of the depth
to which these stories have absolutely
permeated our culture and the loss that
it would be if we didn't know them
properly and,
and take them with the degree of
seriousness that they deserve.
So anyways,
this is one of those great images and
Sarah saw the son of Hagar,
the Egyptian,
which she had born unto Abraham,
mocking.
Wherefore she said unto Abraham,
cast out this bonds woman and her son
for the son of this bonds woman shall
not be heir with my son,
even with Isaac.
And the thing was very grievous in
Abraham's sight because of his son was
being quite a bit of tension between
Abraham or between Sarah and Hagar.
As you could imagine,
there might be.
Why wouldn't there be?
I mean,
first of all,
Hagar had the first child and that
elevated her status and she was,
Sarah's made handmade,
and so that's obviously going to be
quite awkward.
And then she,
um,
she lorded it over Sarah because of the
fact that she got pregnant so easily.
And now we see this situation where
Ishmael is doing the same thing with
regards to Isaac and not causes a
substantial amount of trouble.
The family is a familial division
occurring here.
And God said unto Abraham,
let it not be grievous in eyesight
because of the loud.
And because of the Bond Woman in all
that Sarah Hath said unto the Hearken
unto her voice,
for in Isaac shall thy seed be called
and,
but also of the son of the bond woman,
will I make a nation?
Because he is vi seed.
That's.
So,
that's,
that's an interesting outcome to,
you know,
we,
we pointed out before we discussed
before the fact that because Abraham has
made,
has lived his life properly in his,
kept the contract with God.
There's every evidence in the story that
no matter what the vicissitudes of
Abraham's life,
you know how the great serpent that he
sits on in some sense weaves back and
forth.
There's always the promise that things
will work out positively and you know,
you could read that as naive optimism,
but I think it has a lot more to do with
the actual power of keeping the
contractual agreement.
Because I really do believe and I've
spent a tremendous amount of time
thinking about this over the last couple
of weeks in addition to the decades
before.
That is that.
And,
and,
and all that's happened since I've been
doing these biblical lectures is that my
conviction and this has been
strengthened,
which is quite interesting,
is that if you,
if you do what it is that you're called
upon to do,
which is to lift your eyes up above the
mundane,
daily selfish,
impulsive issues that might be set you
and attempt to enter into a contractual
relationship with that which you might
hold in the highest regard.
Whatever that might be.
To aim high and to,
and to,
and to make that important.
Above all else in your life that,
that fortifies you against the
vicissitudes of existence like nothing
else can.
And I truly believe that that's the most
practical advice that you can possibly,
that you could possibly receive.
You know,
I received,
I was answering questions last night.
I did this q and a,
which I do about once a month for,
um,
for the people who are supporting me on
Patrion which also released on Youtube.
And somebody asked,
you know,
they were struggling with their
religious faith and they asked what they
could do about that.
And I'd also been thinking about the
difference between Nietzsche and
Dostoevsky,
which we'll discuss in a minute.
And I was trying to answer this question
with regards to religious faith because
he,
this person was shaky and his faith in
life,
let's say.
Which is a better way of thinking about
it.
And,
and it seems to me that the way that you
fortify your faith in being and in life
and your own existence isn't to try to
convince yourself of the existence of a
transcendent power that you could
believe in the same way that you believe
in a set of empirical facts.
I don't,
I don't think that's the right approach.
I think it's a weak approach.
Actually.
I don't think that the cognitive
technology that I don't think that's the
right cognitive technology for that set
of problems.
You know,
that's more a technology that you use if
you were trying to solve a scientific
problem.
It's more like it's more something that
needs to be embedded in action rather
than in sustainable belief and the way
that you fortify your faith in life is
to assume the best,
something like that.
And then to act courageously in
relationship to that.
And,
and that's,
that's tantamount to expressing your
faith in the highest possible good.
It's tantamount to expressing your faith
in God.
And it's not a matter of stating,
well,
I believe in the existence of a
transcendent that daddy,
because in some sense,
who cares,
who cares what you believe,
I mean,
you might and all that,
but,
but that's not the issue.
That's not the issue.
The issue,
it seems to me is how you act.
And I was thinking about this intensely
when I was thinking about Nietzsche and
Dostoevsky because of course,
you know that Nietzsche was the
philosopher who announced the death of
God,
right?
And who is a great,
great critic of Christianity at vicious
critic of Institutional Christianity in
the best sense,
you know,
and uh,
you announced the death of God.
And he said that we'd never find enough
water to wash away the blood.
It wasn't a triumphant proclamation even
though it's often read that way and
don't need niches.
Conclusion from that,
from the death of God,
the fact that our ethical systems,
we're going to collapse.
When the foundation was pulled out from
underneath them,
he believed that human beings would have
to find their own values to create their
own values.
And there's a problem with that because
it doesn't seem that this is something
Carl young was very thorough and
investigating.
It doesn't really look like people are
capable of creating their own values
because you're not really capable of
molding yourself just any old way.
You want to be like you have a nature
that you have to contend with,
and so it isn't a matter of creating our
own values because we don't have that
capacity.
It might be a matter of rediscovering
those values,
which is what Jung was attempting to do
now.
And,
and,
and so.
I think nature was actually profoundly
wrong in that,
in that recommendation.
I think he was psychologically wrong.
Now you know,
there was the Esky wrote in many ways in
parallel to.
Nisha was a great influence on Ninja
there.
Their lives parallel each other to a
degree that's somewhat miraculous in
some senses.
It's quite uncanny.
Dostoevsky was obviously a literary
figure,
whether whereas nature was a
philosopher,
a literary philosopher,
but still a philosopher and Dostoevsky
wrestled with exactly the same problems
that,
that nature wrestled with.
And,
but he did it in a different way.
He didn't literary manner and he has
this great book and the Brothers
Karamazov and in that book there's a
hero of the book is really Lee Osha
Who's a monastic novitiate,
a very good guy,
kind of a,
not an intellect,
but uh,
a person of great character,
you know,
but he has a brother Ivan who his older
brother who a great intellect and,
and a very handsome soldier and a brave
man.
And like Dostoyevsky's villains.
See Ivan isn't exactly a villain,
but that's close enough.
Ivan or Dostoevsky makes his villains
extraordinarily powerful.
So if Dostoevsky's trying to work out an
argument,
he,
he clothes the argument in the,
in the flash of one of his characters
and if it's an argument he doesn't agree
with and he makes that character as
strong as he possibly can,
as strong and as attractive and
intelligent as he possibly can.
And then he let some just have outer.
And so Ivan is constantly attacking Lee
Osha and from every direction trying to
knock him off his perch of faith,
let's say.
And the Osha Lee.
Osha can't address a single one of
Ivan's criticisms.
And,
and he doesn't have the intellect for
it.
And,
and,
and Ivan has a devastating intellect.
It's devastating to him himself as well.
What happens in the brothers Karamazov
essentially is the lel.
Osha continues to act out his commitment
to the good,
let's say.
And in that manner he's triumphant.
It doesn't matter that he loses the
arguments because the arguments aren't
exactly the point,
the arguments in some sense,
our aside issue,
because the issue is,
and this is the existential issue,
the issue is not what you believe as if
it's a set of facts,
but how you conduct yourself in the
world.
And so Dostoevsky,
he grasped that and it's one of the
things that makes him such a,
an amazing,
amazing literary figure and amazing
genius because he was smart enough to,
to formulate the arguments in a manner
that no one else really could with the
possible exception of nature.
And that's quite an exception.
And yet he could still using his
dramatic embodiment,
he could still lay out solutions to the
problems that he was describing that are
extremely compelling and both crime and
punishment,
which is an amazing,
thrilling,
engrossing book.
And the brothers Karamazov all of
Dostoyevsky's great books really
circulated around around those profound
moral issues.
And so I've learned a tremendous amount
from,
from reading him so and God said unto
Abraham,
let it not be grievous and eyesight
because of the loud.
And because of that bond woman in all
it's Sarah has said unto Thee,
hearkened unto her voice for a nice,
for in Isaiah,
Excel shall thy seed be called.
And also of the son of the bond woman,
will I make it nation?
Because he is a seed.
All right,
so I commented that Abraham is being
blessed in multiple directions even when
things are going wrong.
And this is pretty bad because his
family in some sense is breaking up the.
There's this emphasis in the text that
because he's kept this contractual
relationship with God,
that,
that he's in an arc.
We could say it,
that we could put it that way.
And that the,
the,
that he'll,
he'll try.
I'm through the vicissitudes of life,
which is the best you can hope for.
And it's quite interesting.
Again,
one of the things that's so powerful
about the abrahamic stories is that it's
not like Abraham,
even though he is chosen by God,
it's not like he has an easy time of it.
He has a rough life.
I mean it's a successful life and all
that,
but it's not,
it's not,
it's not a,
it's not without its troubles,
that's for sure.
It's got every sort of trouble you could
possibly imagine pretty much.
And,
and that's one of the things that makes
the story so realistic as far as I'm
concerned.
And Abraham rose up early in the morning
and took bread and a bottle of water and
gave it unto Hagar,
putting it on her shoulder and the child
and sent her away.
And she departed and wandered in the
wilderness of
yeshiva.
I found the.
It's funny,
I guess this had more of an emotional
impact on me this week than it might
have because my daughter just had a baby
a week ago and so I've been thinking
about this sort of thing,
you know,
we're so happy that that's happened and
I was trying to put yourself in the,
what would you say,
the conceptual space of the people about
who this stories or people who these
stories are about and trying to,
you know,
notice the catastrophe that this sort of
breakup would actually constitute.
And No,
and the visual images really helped with
that because they're,
they're so carefully crafted and,
and they hit the story from so many
different directions that,
you know,
they add that an additional layer of
emotional meaning to it,
which I found very,
very significant.
And the water was spent in the bottle
and she cast the child under one of the
shrubs and she sent to wandering the
desert,
you know?
So it's not just that she has to leave
Abraham's household,
it's that where she goes,
it's not really amenable to life.
And so it's,
it's extraordinarily dramatic and and,
and terrible tale,
and she went and sat her down over
against him,
a good way off as it were,
a bowshot for.
She said,
let me not see the death of the child.
And she sat over against him and lift up
her voice and wept,
and God heard the voice of the loud and
the angel of God called to Hagar out of
heaven and said unto her what Aileth
Hagar,
fear not for God hath heard the voice of
the lad where he is rise.
Lift up the lad and hold them in nine
hand for I will make him a great nation.
And God opened her eyes and she saw a
well of water and she went and filled
the bottle with water and gave the lead
drink.
And God was with the loud and he grew
and dwelt in the wilderness and became
an archer.
That's actually irrelevant detail to
that.
The fact that he became an archer,
because I think I mentioned to you at
one point that the word sin is derived
from a Greek word Amartya.
Even though it sounds nothing like that
word,
Hamartia is actually a an archery term
and it means to,
it means to miss the Bullseye and that's
a.
that's a lovely metaphor for sand.
I think because it's associated so
tightly with the idea of,
of goal direction and an aim,
you know,
because there's an,
there's a metaphorical idea that's
embedded in that,
in that image and that is that,
you know,
a human being is something that
specifies a target,
which we do all the time with her eyes.
By the way,
I mean our eyes,
our target specifying mechanisms.
You know,
we have very precise central focal
vision and we use our focal vision to
target the aim of our behavior.
And so we are aiming creatures.
There's are,
it's built right into our plot,
our body,
or we're.
We're built on a hunting platform.
We're aiming creatures and we do that
cognitively as well as behaviorally.
And so as hunters,
we take aim at things that we take aim
at moving targets and we're very good at
bringing them down and we'd been doing
that for who knows how long,
millions of years really.
Even chimpanzees are carnivorous by the
way,
and we split from them about 6 million
years ago,
so we've been hunting and aiming for a
very,
very long period of time and we still
have aims in our life.
Right.
And that's how we describe them.
What are you aiming at or what are your
aims,
what are your goals,
what's your target?
It's all based on that hunting metaphor
and the fact that Ishmael becomes an
archer means that he is someone who can
take aim at the center of the Bullseye
and hit it precisely.
And so that's an indication that he's a
good man.
Right?
So,
and,
and I suppose also part of the part of
it carries part of the narrative weight
of the story because of course he's
Abraham's son and you'd expect Abraham's
son to be someone who's very good at
taking aim and he dwelt in the
wilderness of Paran and he could live
there and survive,
which is no trivial thing.
And his mother took him a wife out of
the land of Egypt.
Okay.
So that's the story of Hagar and it's a
fairly straightforward story.
It's complex emotionally,
but it doesn't and it and it.
It brings up the terrible theme of a
familial catastrophe and the
complications of of romantic and
familial relationships and all of that,
but it really serves as a prodrome on to
the next story,
which is the one that's so complex and
so difficult to understand
and it came to pass after these things
that God did tempt Abraham,
which is a funny thing for God to do,
I suppose,
and said unto him Abraham,
and he said,
behold,
here I am,
and God said,
take now thy son the only son,
Isaac,
who who they'll love us and get thee
into the land of Moriah and offer him
there for a burnt offering upon one of
the mountains which I will tell the of,
and Abraham rose up early in the morning
and saddled his ass and took two of his
young men with him and Isaac his son and
clave the wood for the burnt offering
and rose up and went under the place of
which God had told him.
Then on the third day of journeying,
Abraham lifted up his eyes and saw the
place afar off and Abraham said unto his
young men,
abide he,
he here with the ass and I and the lad
will go yonder and worship and come
again to you.
It's really one of the first times that
we've come across the word worship,
if I remember correctly,
and it's a very difficult word to
contend with to know because if you're
like me or if you're like me when I was
a kid,
because I haven't thought about this for
a long time,
it was never really obvious to me why
God would want to be worshiped.
You know,
if you go to church and you offer up
your praise and thanks to God and you
think,
well relate.
Does that make a lot of sense?
It's like,
why in the world is that what he wants?
it's almost like you're,
you're,
you're
kneeling down in front of an,
of an ancient,
Middle Eastern,
you know,
tyrannical emperor and,
and,
and vowing your submission.
And that never sat well with me.
And I,
I suppose it doesn't sit well with many
people and I think that's because it's
not the proper way of conceptualizing
it.
What happens when you see what Abraham
does continually,
and this seems to be implicit in the use
of the word worship in this particular
situation,
is that he,
as we discussed,
he,
he has an adventure in his life that
comes to an end.
So there's an episode in his life,
it comes to an end and then there's a
period of we might consider it re where
you reconstitute himself to some degree
and it's.
That's when he makes his sacrifices.
And it seems to me that it's that
reconstitution that constitutes the
worship.
The worship is something like,
you know,
this is alluding back to my original
proposition,
that it's how you act.
That's the issue.
And the worship is the decision to enact
the good in whatever form it is that you
can conceptualize it as well as trying
to continually reconceptualize the good
in a manner that makes the good,
that you're conceptualizing even that
much better.
Right?
Because when you start aiming,
the probability that you're going to be
aiming in the right direction is very
low,
but hypothetically as you aim and as
practice and as you learn,
the target is going to shift in front of
your eyes and you're going to be able to
follow whatever more clearly and so that
seems to me,
and especially given the context that
this word is used in this particular
story is much more appropriate
interpretation of what constitutes
proper worship.
And I suppose it's akin to the later
Christian idea that it's the imitation
of Christ.
That's the sacred duty of every
Christian,
every Christian and every human being.
I suppose in so far as that's an
archetypal idea.
An idea is something like,
well,
it's the embodiment of the good.
That's the issue and it's not your
stated belief in the good and you know
when nature was criticized and
Christianity.
This is actually one of the things that
he brought up as a as a major issue.
He said that he believed Christianity
had lost its way because it had
introduced a confusion between stated
belief,
which is say your belief in the divinity
of Christ.
Whatever it means.
If you state that it isn't obvious what
it means,
that when you state that because it
isn't obvious what it would mean that
you believe it or even what it is that
you're believing in.
As far as Nietzsche was concerned.
In some sense,
not only was that beside the point,
it was dangerously beside the point
because it actually allowed the
Christian believer not to adopt the
moral burden that was actually
appropriate to the faith which was to.
And this is.
I'm using a kind of a union concept here
to manifest the archetype within the
confines of your own life.
And that's to make the divine that your
relationship with the divine,
your relationship with the transcendent
and infinite into something that's
actually realized bubble in the context
of your own life.
Which is to say,
well,
you know,
you're supposed to.
You're supposed to,
again,
to act out the highest good of which
you're capable.
Now.
That'll transform your life.
To some degree,
into an archetypal adventure,
there is no way around that because as
you attempt to climb a higher mountain,
let's say,
or to aim at a higher target or
something like that,
then the things around you will become
increasingly dramatic and of import.
That happens by necessity obviously
because if you're aiming at something
difficult and profound and you're really
working on it,
then your life is going to become
perhaps increasingly difficult and
profound,
but that might be okay.
You might.
That might be exactly what you need as
an antidote to the implicit limitations
that say,
see you as a human being so and I and
the lad will go yonder and worship and
come again to you.
Now,
there's an implication here too that
it's a foreshadowing that Abraham
offering up his son is actually a form
of worship and that's that it's
continuous with what he's already done
and well now I'm going to read you some
of the things that I've written and then
I'll return to this and we'll see how
that goes.
So
life is suffering.
That's clear.
There is no more basic,
irrefutable truth.
It's basically as we've seen what God
tells Adam and Eve immediately before he
kicks them out of Paradise,
quote unto the woman,
he said,
I will greatly multiply thy sorrow and
thy conception in sorrow,
thou shall bring forth children and that
desire shall be to the husband and he
shall rule over thee and unto Adam he
said,
because you have hearkened unto the
voice of thy wife and hast eaten of the
tree which I commanded thee,
saying,
thou shalt not eat of it.
Cursed is the ground for the sake in
sorrow shall thou eat of it all the days
of thy life,
thorns also and thistles shall it bring
forth to thee and thou shalt eat the
herb of the field.
By the sweat of your brow,
you will eat your food until you return
to the ground.
Since from it you were taken for dust,
you are and to dust,
you will return rough.
You know,
and we've associated that with,
with Adam and Eve's eyes opening and
them becoming self conscious and
discovering the future and becoming
fully aware and falling into history.
And it seems to me to be a very
realistic existential portrayal of the
predicament of humankind.
What in the world should be done about
that?
The simplest,
most obvious and most direct answer,
pursue pleasure.
Follow your impulses.
Live for the moment.
Do what's expedient.
Lie,
cheat,
steal,
deceive,
manipulate,
but don't get caught in an ultimately
meaningless universe.
What possible difference could it make?
And this is by no means a new idea.
The fact of life tragedy and the
suffering that is part of it has been
used to justify the pursuit of immediate
selfish gratification for a very long
time,
no,
even reading young,
he often writes as if before the rise of
the conflict between religion and
science and which culminated say in
niches pronouncement about the death of
God,
that people lived ensconced quite safely
within a religious conceptualization
that abused their life with meaning and
that that was,
and that was just the state of reality,
you know,
but there's ancient writings that makes
it quite clear that the crisis of faith
that characterize,
say modern people were certainly far
from unknown in the past.
And here's one of those writings.
This is from wisdom to the revised
standard version,
short and sorrowful is our life and
there is no remedy when a man comes to
his end and no one has been known to
return from Haiti's because we were born
by mere chance and hereafter.
We shall be as though we had never been
because the breath in our nostrils is
smoke and reason is just a spark kindled
by the beating of our hearts.
When it is extinguished,
our body will turn to ashes and their
spirit will dissolve like empty air.
Our Name
will be forgotten in time and no one
will remember our works.
Our life will pass away like the traces
of a cloud and be scattered like mist
that is chased by the rays of the sun
and overcome by its heat for our
allotted time is about the passing of
the shadow and there is no return from
our death because it is sealed up and no
one turns back.
Come.
Therefore,
let us enjoy the good things that exist
and make use of the creation to the
full.
As in youth.
Let us take our fill of costly wines and
perfumes and let know flower of spring
passes by.
Let us crown ourselves with rosebuds
before they wither.
Let none of us fail to share in our
revelry everywhere.
Let us leave signs of enjoyment because
this is our portion and this is our lot.
Let us oppress.
Press the righteous,
poor man.
Let us not spare the widow nor regard
the gray hairs of the aged,
but let her might be are right for what
is weak proves itself to be useless.
It's an amazing
piece of writing.
You know it.
It starts with an announcement of the
rationale for nihilism and ends with a
justification for fastest tyranny.
You know,
and it's,
it's thousands of years old.
It's,
it's a remarkable thing to see and to be
laid out so concisely.
The pleasure of expediency may be
fleeting,
but it's pleasure nonetheless,
and that's something to stack up against
the terror and pain of existence.
Every man for himself and the devil.
Take the hindmost as the old proverb has
it.
Why not simply take everything you can
get whenever the opportunity arises,
why not determined to live in that
manner?
What's the alternative and why should we
bother with it?
Our ancestors worked out very
sophisticated answers to such questions,
but we still don't understand them very
well.
This is because they are in large part,
still implicit manifest primarily in
ritual and myth,
and as of yet incompletely articulated,
we act them out and represent them in
stories,
but we're not wise enough yet to
formulate them explicitly.
We're still chimps in a troop or wolves
in the pack.
We know how to behave.
We know who's who and why.
We've learned that through experience.
Our knowledge has been shaped by our
interaction with others.
We've established predictable routines
and patterns of behavior,
but we don't really understand them or
know where they originated.
Maybe evolved over great expanses of
time.
No one was formulating them explicitly,
at least not in the dimmest reaches of
the past,
even though we've been telling each
other how to act forever.
One day,
however,
not so long ago,
we woke up,
we were already doing,
but we noticing what we
were doing.
We started using our bodies as devices
to represent their own actions.
We started imitating and dramatizing.
We invented ritual.
We started acting out our own
experiences.
Then we started to tell stories.
We coded our observations of our own
drama in those stories,
in this manner.
The information that was first only
embedded in our behavior became
represented in our stories,
but we didn't and we still don't
understand what it all meant.
The Biblical narrative of Paradise in
the fall is one such story fabricated by
our collective imagination working over
the centuries.
It provides a profound account of the
nature of being and points the way to a
motive conceptualization and action well
matched to that nature in the garden of
Eden prior to the dawn of self
consciousness,
so goes the story.
Human beings were sinless.
Our primordial parents,
Adam and Eve walked with God.
They hadn't attempted by the snake.
The first couple ate from the tree of
the knowledge of good and evil,
discovered death and vulnerability and
turned away from God.
Mankind was exiled from paradise and
began it's effortful,
mortal existence,
the idea of sacrifice enter soon
afterwards,
beginning with the account of Cain and
Abel and developing as we've seen
through the abrahamic stories,
after much contemplation,
struggling humanity learns that God's
favor could be gained and his wrath
averted through proper sacrifice,
and also that bloody murder might be
motivated among those unwilling or
unable to succeed in this manner.
When engaging in sacrifice,
our forefathers began to act out what
would be considered a proposition if it
were stated in words that something
better might be attained in the future
by giving up something of value in the
present.
Recall,
if you will,
that the necessity for work is one of
the curses placed by God upon out of
Man,
his descendants in consequence of
original sin.
Adam's waking to the fundamental
constraints of his being,
his vulnerability,
his eventual death that's equivalent to
the discovery of the future.
The future.
That's where you go to die.
Hopefully not too soon.
Your demise might be staved off through
work,
through the sacrifice of the now to
benefit later.
It is for this reason,
among others,
no doubt that the concept of sacrifice
is introduced in the biblical chapter
immediately following the drama of the
fall.
There's little difference between
sacrifice and work.
They're also both uniquely human.
Sometimes animals act as if
they're working,
but they're really only following the
dictates of their natures.
Beavers build dams.
They do so because they're beavers and
beavers build dams.
They don't think,
yeah,
but I'd rather be on a beach in Mexico
with my girlfriend while they're doing
it.
Prosaically such sacrifice work is delay
of gratification,
but that's a very mundane phrase to
describe something of soul shattering
significance.
The discovery that gratification could
be delayed was simultaneously the
discovery of time and with it causality
long ago in the dim mists of time,
we began to realize that reality was
structured as if it could be bargained
with.
We learned that behaving properly now in
the present,
regulating our impulses,
considering the plight of others could
bring rewards in the future in a time
and place that did not yet exist.
We began to inhibit control and organize
our immediate impulses so that we could
stop interfering with other people and
our future selves doing so was
indistinguishable from organizing
society.
The discovery of the causal relationship
between our efforts today and the
quality of tomorrow motivated the social
contract,
the organization that enables today's
work to be stored reliably,
mostly in the form of promises from
others.
Understanding is something that's often
acted out before it can be articulated
just as a child,
acts out what it means to be mother or
father before being able to give a
spoken account of what those roles mean.
The idea,
the act of making a ritual sacrifice to
God was an early and sophisticated
enactment of the idea of the usefulness
of delay.
There is a long conceptual journey
between merely feasting,
hungrily and learning to set aside some
extra meat smoke by the fire for the end
of the day or for someone who isn't
present.
It takes a long time to learn to keep
anything later for yourself or to share
it with someone else,
and those are very much the same thing
as in the former case.
You're sharing with your future self.
It's much easier and far more likely to
selfishly and immediately wolf down
everything in sight.
There are similar long journeys between
every leap and sophistication with
regards to delay and its
conceptualization,
short term sharing,
storing away from the further future
representation of that storage in the
form of records and later in the form of
currency and ultimately the saving of
money in a bank or other institution.
Some conceptualizations had serve as
intermediaries or the full range of our
practices and ideas surrounding
sacrifice and work and their
representation could have never emerged.
Our ancestors acted out a drama,
a literary fiction.
They persona fired the forest,
that governance fate as a spirit that
can be bargained with,
traded with as if it were another human
being,
and the amazing thing is that it worked.
This was in part because the future is
largely composed of other human beings,
often precisely those who have watched
an evaluated and appraise the tiniest
details of your past behavior.
It's not very far from that to God
sitting above on high tracking your
every move and writing it down for
further reference.
In a big book here is a productive,
symbolic idea.
The future is a judgmental father.
That's a good start,
but two additional archetype or
foundational questions that arose
because of the discovery of sacrifice of
work both have to do with the ultimate
extension of the logic of work,
which is sacrifice now to gain later.
First question,
what must be sacrificed?
Small sacrifices might be sufficient to
small to solve small singular problems,
but it's possible that larger,
more comprehensive sacrifices might
solve an array of large and complex
problems all at the same time.
That's harder,
but it might be better adapting to the
necessary discipline of medical school,
for example,
will fatally interfere with the
licentious lifestyle of a hardcore
undergraduate party animal giving that
up as a sacrifice,
but a physician can.
To quote George,
w really put food on his family that's a
lot of trouble dispensed with over a
very long period of time,
so sacrifices are necessary to improve
the future and larger sacrifices can be
better.
Second question,
introduction.
We've already established the basic
principle sacrifice will improve the
future,
but what's implied by that in the most
extreme and final of cases,
where does that basic principle find its
limits?
We must ask to begin with what would be
the largest,
most effective,
most pleasing of all possible
sacrifices,
and then how good might the best
possible future be if the most effective
possible sacrifice could be made.
The Biblical story of Cain and Abel,
Adam and Eve sons immediately follows
the story of the expulsion from
paradise.
As mentioned previously,
Cain and Abel are really the first
humans since their parents were made
directly by God and not born in the
standard manner.
Cain and Abel live in history,
not in Eden.
They must work.
They must make sacrifices to please God
and they do so with alter and proper
ritual,
but things get complicated.
Ables offerings please God,
but do not able is rewarded many times
over,
but Kane is not.
It's not precisely clear why,
although the tech strongly hints that
Keynes Heart is just not in it.
Maybe the quality of what came put
forward was low.
Maybe his spirit was begrudging or maybe
God was just feeding crabby and all of
this is realistic,
including the texts,
vagueness of explanation.
Not all sacrifices are of equal quality.
Furthermore,
it often appears that sacrifices of
apparently high quality are sometimes
not rewarded with a better future and
it's not clear why.
Why isn't God happy?
What would have to change to make him
so?
These are difficult questions and
everyone asks them all the time,
even if they don't notice.
Asking such questions is
indistinguishable from thinking.
The realization that pleasure could be
usefully for stole dormed with a
difficulty that's almost impossible to
overstate such a realization runs
absolutely contrary to our ancient
fundamental animal instincts which
demand immediate satisfaction,
particularly under conditions of
deprivation,
which are both inevitable and
commonplace,
and to complicate the matter,
such delay only becomes useful when
civilization has stabilized itself
enough to guarantee the existence of the
delayed reward.
If everything you save will be destroyed
or worse,
stolen,
there's no point saving.
It's for this reason that a wolf will
down 20 pounds of raw meat in a single
meal.
He isn't thinking,
man,
I hate it when I binge.
I should save some of this for next
week.
Here's a developmental progression from
animal to human.
It's wrong,
no doubt in the details,
but it's sufficiently correct for our
purposes in theme first,
there's excess food,
large carcasses,
mammoths or other massive herbivores
might provide that way.
A lot of mamas,
maybe all of them with a large animal,
there's some left for later after a kill
that's accidental at first,
but eventually the utility of for later
starts to be appreciated.
Some provisional notion of sacrifice
develops at the same time.
If I leave some now,
even if I want it now,
I won't have to be hungry later.
That provision will notion then develops
to the next level.
If I leave some for later,
I won't have to go hungry and neither
will those I care for and then to the
next level.
I can't possibly eat all this mammoth,
but I can't store the rest for too long
either.
Maybe I should feed some to other
people.
Maybe they'll remember and feed me some
of their mammoth when they have some and
I have none.
Then I'll get some mammoth now and some
mammoth later.
That's a good deal
and maybe those I'm sharing with will
come to trust me more generally.
Maybe then we could trade forever in
such a manner.
Mammoth becomes future,
mammoth and future.
Mammoth becomes personal reputation.
That's the emergence of the social
contract to share does not mean to give
away something you value and get nothing
back.
That's the only.
Instead what every child who refuses to
share his afraid that it means to share
means properly to initiate the process
of trade.
A child who can't share,
you can't trade,
can't have any friends because having
friends is a form of trade.
Benjamin Franklin once suggested that a
newcomer to a neighborhood ask a new
neighbor to do him or her a favor citing
an old maxim.
He that has one stun you.
A kindness will be more ready to do
another.
Then he whom you yourself have obliged
in Franklin,
so opinion asking something for someone,
asking someone for something not too
extreme obviously was the most useful
and immediate invitation to social
interaction.
Such asking allowed the neighbor to show
him or herself as a good person at first
encounter.
It also meant that the neighbor could
now ask the newcomer for a favor in
return because of the debt incurred in
that manner,
both parties could overcome their
natural hesitancy and mutual fear of the
stranger.
It's better to have something rather
than nothing.
It's better yet to generously share the
something you have.
It's even better than that.
However,
to become widely known for generous
sharing,
that's something that lasts.
That's something that's reliable,
and at this point in abstraction,
we can observe how the groundwork for
the conceptions of reliable,
honest and generous have been laid.
The basis for an articulated morality
has been put in place.
The productive truthful sharer is the
prototype for the good citizen and the
good man we can see in this manner how
from the simple notion that leftovers
are a good idea,
the highest moral principles might
emerge.
It's as if something like this happened
as humanity developed first.
We're the endless tens or hundreds of
thousands of years prior to the
emergence of written history and drama.
During this time,
the twin practices of delay and exchange
began to emerge slowly and painfully.
Then they became represented in
metaphorical abstraction as rituals and
tales of sacrifice totaled in a manner
such as this.
It's as if there is a powerful figure in
the sky who sees all and is judging you,
giving up something you value seems to
make them happy and you to make them
happy because all hell breaks loose if
you don't,
so practice sacrificing and sharing
until you become expert at it and things
will go well for you.
No one said any of this,
at least not so plainly and directly,
but it was implicit in the practice and
then in the stories.
Action came first as it had to,
as the animals we once were,
could act but could not think.
Implicit unrecognized value came first
as the actions that proceeded thought
embodied value,
but did not make that value explicit.
People watched the successful succeed
and the unsuccessful fail for thousands
and thousands of years.
We thought it over and we drew a
conclusion.
The successful among us delay
gratification,
the successful among us bargain with the
future.
A great idea began to emerge taking ever
more clearly articulated forum in
evermore clearly articulated stories.
What's the difference between the
successful and the unsuccessful,
the successful sacrifice things get
better as the successful practice,
their sacrifices,
the questions become increasingly
precise and simultaneously broader.
What's the greatest possible sacrifice
for the greatest possible good and the
answer become increasingly deeper and
profound.
The God of western tradition like so
many gods requires sacrifice.
We've already examined why,
but sometimes he goes even further.
He demands not only sacrifice,
but the sacrifice of precisely what is
love best.
This is most starkly portrayed and most
confusingly evident in the story of
Abraham and Isaac.
Abraham beloved of God long wanted a son
and God promised them exactly that after
many delays and under the apparently
impossible conditions of old age and the
long barren wife,
but not so long afterward,
when the miraculously born,
Isaac is still a child.
God turns around and in apparently
barbaric fashion demands that is
faithful servant,
offer his son as a sacrifice.
The story ends happily.
God sends an angel to stay Abraham's
obedient hand and accepts a ram and
Isaac stead.
Now it's a good thing,
but it doesn't really address the issue
at hand.
Why was God's going further necessary?
Why does he?
Why does life impose such demands?
Let's start our analysis with a truism
stark self evident and understated.
Sometimes things do not go well that to
have much to do with the terrible nature
of the world with its plagues and it's
famines and it's tyrannies and it's
betrayals,
but here's the rub.
Sometimes when things are not going
well,
it's not the world that it's the cause.
The cause is instead that which is most
valued.
Why?
Because the world is revealed to an
intermittent degree through the template
of your values.
If the world you are seeing is not the
world you want,
therefore it's time to examine your
values.
It's time to rid yourself of your
current presuppositions.
It's time to let go.
It might even be time to sacrifice what
you love best so that you can become who
you might become instead of staying who
you are,
something valuable given up.
Insurers fused future prosperity,
something valuable,
sacrificed,
pleases the Lord.
What is most valuable and best
sacrificed or what does at least
emblematic of that,
a choice cut of meat,
the best animal in a flock,
a most valued possession.
What's above even that something
intensely personal and painful to give
up that symbolized perhaps in God's
insistence on circumcision as part of
Abraham sacrificial routine.
What's beyond that?
What pertains more closely to the whole
person rather than the part?
What constitutes the ultimate sacrifice
for the gain of the ultimate prize?
It's a close race between child and
self.
The sacrifice of the mother offering her
child to the world is exemplified.
For example,
by Michelangelo,
great sculpture,
the Pieta,
Michelangelo Crafted Mary Contemplating
Her Son,
crucified in ruins,
so she's sitting.
Most of you know this sculpture.
She's sitting and the body of her son is
in her arms,
her adult son,
and it's broken and he's been destroyed
and it's a very beautiful but very
tragic
work of genius work of genius level
representation.
Michelangelo crafted Mary Contemplating
Her Son,
crucified and rude.
It's her fault.
It was through her that he entered the
world and it's great drama of Ba.
Is it right to bring a baby into this
terrible world?
Every woman asks herself that question.
Some say no,
and they have their reasons.
Mary answers,
yes,
voluntarily knowing full well what's to
come as do all mothers if they allow
themselves to see it's an act of supreme
courage when it's undertaken
voluntarily.
In turn,
Mary Sung Christ offers himself to God
and the world to be trailed,
torture and death to the very point of
despair on the cross where he cries out
those terrible words,
my God,
my why hast thou forsaken me?
That is the archetipal story of the man
who gives his all for the sake of the
better,
who offers up his life for the
advancement of being who allows God's
will to become manifest fully within the
confines of a single mortal life.
That is the model for the honorable man
in Christ case.
However,
as he sacrifices himself,
God,
his father is simultaneously sacrificing
his son.
It's for this reason that the Christian
sacrificial drama of Sun and self is
archetipal.
It's a story at the limit where nothing
more extreme,
nothing greater can be imagined.
That's the very definition of
archetypical.
That's the core of what constitutes
religious pain and suffering.
Define the world of that.
There can be no doubt.
Sacrifice can hold pain and suffering in
a balance to a greater or lesser degree,
and greater sacrifices can do that more
effectively than lesser of that too.
There can be no doubt.
Everyone holds this knowledge in their
soul,
thus the person who wishes to alleviate
suffering,
who wishes to rectify the flaws and
being who wishes to bring about the best
of all possible futures,
who wants to create heaven on earth will
make the greatest of sacrifices of self
and child of everything that is loved to
live a life aimed at the good he will
forego expediency.
He will pursue the path of ultimate
meaning and he will in that manner bring
salvation to the ever desperate world.
Thanks.
On the third day,
Abraham lifted up his eyes and saw the
place far off.
It's not an accident also did in the
mountain,
right?
Because a mountain is something you have
to climb and you have to climb to the
pinnacle of a mountain and the mountain
is operate in.
The mountain,
stretches up to heaven,
and it's a long journey to specify the
right place on the highest pinnacle,
and that's symbolic because of course
it's a pinnacle that you're always
trying to reach.
Just like you're always trying to aim.
You're always trying to climb upward.
At least that's the theory,
depends to some degree of course on your
definition of upward.
And Abraham said to his young men,
abide he here with us and I and the lad
will go yonder and worship and come to
you again.
And Abraham took the wood of the burnt
offering and laid it upon Isaac,
his son,
and he took the fire in hand and a knife
and they went both of them together and
Isaac spake unto Abraham his father and
said,
my father.
And he said,
here are my my son.
behold the fire in the wood,
but where is the lamb for a burnt
offering?
And Abraham said,
my son,
God will provide himself a lamb for a
burnt offering.
So they went both of them together
and they came to the place which God had
told him of,
and Abraham built an altar there and
laid the wood in order and bound Isaac
his son,
and laid him on the alter upon the wood.
And Abraham stretched forth his hand and
took the knife to slay his son.
And the angel of the Lord called unto
him out of Heaven and said Abraham.
And he said,
here am I.
and the Angel said,
lay not dine.
Hand upon the lad.
Neither do thou anything unto him.
For now I know that Thou [inaudible]
God.
Seeing thou has not withheld thy son an
only son from me.
When I was answering the questions last
night at this q and a,
this guy asked me this question.
He said that he had parents who were
desperate,
anti social alcoholic addicted
friendless,
and that they didn't want him to leave
their home.
He was the only relationship they had
that that was up.
and he asked what he should do and I
told him that he should leave,
and the reason for that is that you have
a moral obligation as a parent too.
Encourage your child to go out into the
world,
right,
and to be whoever they can be to be the
best they can possibly be.
And in doing that you're offering,
you're encouraging them to pursue the
good.
You're sacrificing them to the good.
You're not keeping them for yourself
selfishly.
You're telling them that they can go out
and live their life and live it
properly.
And,
and that's the parallel to the idea of
the sacrifice of Isaac as far as I can
tell you don't want for your son what it
is that you want him,
you want for your son.
What would be best for him and for the
world,
and you let go in precise proportion to
your desire to have that happen.
You know the psychoanalysts,
the great psychoanalyst,
psychoanalyst,
I think this is actually Freud's dictum,
but I'm not certain of that.
He said the good mother fails,
which is a bit of brilliant observation
because when you have an infant do you
do everything for the infant because the
infant can do nothing for him or
herself,
but as the infant matures and this
increasingly capable of doing things for
him or herself,
then you pull back,
right?
You pull back and every time the child
develops the ability to do something,
you allow them or encourage them to do
it and you don't interfere.
You know?
So if your child is struggling,
getting dressed,
well obviously there's some times that
you helped them,
but mostly you let them learn so that
they can know how to do it in the
future.
That's better for you.
And it's certainly better for them.
There's a rule if you're working with
the elderly and an old age home and the
rule is something like,
oh,
don't do anything for any of the.
For any of the guests,
let's say that they can do for
themselves because you compromise their
independence.
And so as a mother,
you pull back and you pull back and you
let your child hit him or herself
against the world and you fail to
protect them,
but by failing to protect them,
you encourage and enable them to the
point where you're no longer necessary.
Now,
they may still want to see you and it
would be wonderful if that was the case,
but the point is is that you're supposed
to remove yourself from the equation by
encouraging your child to be the best
possible person that person can be,
and you sacrifice your desires,
all of your desires to that,
your personal desires,
even your desires for your child in
relationship to you because you want
them to move forward into the world as a
light,
right?
As a light on a hill.
That's what you want.
If you have any sense,
and so you don't get to keep your
children at home because you need them.
Now I'm talking generally obviously,
and there are circumstances under which
families make their own idiosyncratic
decisions.
And I'm not trying to damn everyone with
a with a casual gesture,
you know,
but the point is still strong that
the good father is precisely someone who
is willing to sacrifice this child to
the ultimate good that's dramatized in
this store,
you know,
and it's brutal,
but the world is a brutal place and much
wisdom comes out of catastrophe and this
is an indication of how much catastrophe
our ancestors had to plow through,
had to work through in order to generate
the substructure for the conceptions of
freedom even that we have today for
freedom and the.
And that's how the story appears to me.
Now.
I think there's more to it.
I think if there has to be more to it,
it lays the groundwork,
at least in the Christian context,
for the eventual emergence of Christ.
As I alluded to in my reading.
That story obviously has to be unpacked
and unpacked and unpacked just like it
has been for the last 2000 years.
It's also an indication here of,
well I would say the transmutation of
sacrifice into an increasingly
psychological forum,
which is a development that we've
tracked all the way through the Old
Testament,
up to this particular point.
First act it out,
then represented in ritual.
Those would be the rituals of sacrifice.
Then laid out in story then turned into
a psychological phenomena so that now
we're capable of making sacrifices in
abstraction,
right,
to conceptualize a future that we want
to let go of the things that are
stopping us from moving forward and to
free ourselves from the chains of our
original preconceptions and that's laid
out in these old stories as the optimal
pathway of being
and there's a philosopher of science
named Karl Popper,
very sensible and down to earth person
who was talking about thinking and it's
nature,
and he was thought about thinking in a
Darwinian fashion.
He said,
the purpose of thinking is too late.
Your thoughts die instead of you so
brilliant notion,
and so the idea is something like that.
You can conjure up a representation of
yourself.
You can conjure up a variety of
potential representations of yourself
into the in the future.
You can lay out how those future
representations of yourself are likely
to prevail or fail.
You can call the potential use in the
future that will fail and then you can
embody the ones that will succeed.
You do that well simultaneously
conjuring up a representation of your
current state and determining for
yourself because of your undo suffering,
which elements of your pathetic being
needed to be given up so that you can
move forward into that future and the
goal.
What is it that you're aiming at with
that work and that sacrifice?
That's the ultimate question.
It's the question I was trying to
address in that writing.
What is it that you're trying to do?
What you're trying to improve the
future?
We believe that the future can be
improved.
We believed that it can be improved as a
consequence of our sacrificial work,
and so once again,
what are the limitations?
What are the limits to that?
What are the necessary limits to that?
I would say we don't know.
I would say as well that that's actually
something that the entire Corpus of
biblical stories is trying desperately
to articulate,
to figure out and articulate,
right?
We,
we,
we conjured up this remarkable idea.
The future exists.
We can see it even though it's only
potential.
We can adjust our behavior in the
present in order to maximize our
probability of success in the future.
How best to do that?
Well,
the idea is something like,
don't hesitate to offer the ultimate
sacrifice if you want the future to turn
out ultimately.
Well now obviously that idea is clothed
in metaphysical speculation and
religious imagery,
but it still remains an intensely
practical issue,
right?
What is it that you could contract for?
Let's say if you were willing to give up
everything about you that's weak and
unworthy.
The,
there's a,
there's a continual hints of that in the
Old Testament,
right?
Because what happens with no of course
is that
he establishes the proper covenant with
God,
the proper contract with being,
let's say,
and thrives as a consequence,
and then Abraham does the same thing.
There's a strong intimation that that's
how the world is set right now.
That idea develops and magnifies as the
stories progress into something like
into something like the concept of
heaven on earth.
The notion being that the proper
sacrificial additude produces a
psychological state and then the social
state.
That's a manifestation of that attitude
that decreases the probability that the
world will careen into hell and
increases the probability that people
will live high quality,
meaningful private lives in a society
that's balanced and capable of
supporting that and none of that seems
to me to be
questionable.
Really.
I also don't think it's anything that
people don't actually know.
You know,
people have told me many times that when
they listened to me talk,
they're hearing things that they already
know knew,
but didn't know how to say.
It's something like that,
and this is one of those things that I
think is exactly like that.
I mean,
I think it's at the very core of our
moral knowledge and which is our
behavioral knowledge and our perceptual
knowledge.
I mean,
let's get this straight.
Moral knowledge is no trivial matter.
It's knowledge about how it is that you
orient yourself in the world.
There's no more profoundly necessary
form of knowledge.
Well,
it's predicated on on something that's
exactly like this.
We know that we have to make sacrifices.
We know that we have to aim at what's
good,
so then why isn't that we don't aim at
what's best and make the sacrifices that
are necessary in order to bring that
into play.
I think it seems to me that in some
sense that's self.
The question
is why we don't do it,
but there's answers to that to already
in the material that we've covered.
Life is hard and it hurts people.
It's rife with limitation and some of
it's arbitrary and it's no wonder and
some of it's unjust and some of its
worst.
Some of it's malevolent,
which is even worse than something I
haven't talked about at all in this
lecture.
It's not surprising that that
combination of vicissitude can turn
people against being,
but I think even when that happens and
even when people have the kind of
history that if they revealed to you,
you would say,
well,
it's no wonder you turned out that way.
The people who turn out that way still
know that it's wrong.
They still know that however deep their
own suffering,
however arbitrary their own suffering,
however much that's caused by the
malevolence of others,
as well as the tragedy of existence,
that that does not in any way justify
they're turning away from the good and I
believe everyone knows that I believe
that they know it implicitly,
even if they don't allow themselves to
know what explicitly and I believe that
if they violate that idea,
then they violate themselves and that
they end up in cains position,
which is the position of the man who's
been given a punishment that is too
great to bear,
and the angel said,
thank you
les,
not dying.
Hand upon the loud.
Neither do without anything unto him.
For now I know that Thou [inaudible] God
seeing thou has not withheld thy son.
They only son from me and Abraham lifted
up his eyes and looked and behold behind
him,
a ram caught in the thicket body has
thorns by his horns and Abraham went and
took the ram and offered him up for a
burnt offering instead of his son and
Abraham called the name of that place.
Jehovah Zero.
As it is said to this day in the mount
of the Lord,
it shall be seat and the angel of the
Lord called Unto Abraham Out of heaven
the second time and said by myself,
have I sworn Sayeth the Lord for because
Thou hast done this thing and it has not
withheld thy son die.
And only son that in blessing I will
bless thee.
And in multiplying I will multiply thy
seed as the stars of the heaven and as
the sand which is upon the seashore and
thy seed shall possess the gates of his
gate of his enemies.
And in thy seed shall all the nations of
the Earth be blessed because thou hast
obeyed my voice.
So Abraham
returned unto his young men and they
rose up and went together to Beersheba.
And Abraham dwelled had Beersheba and it
came to pass after these things that it
was told Abraham saying,
behold,
milka she has also born children unto
thy brother [inaudible] whore.
And Sarah was 107 and 20 years old.
Those were the years of the life of
Sarah and Sarah died,
encourage,
uh,
the same as Hebrew in the land of
Canaan.
And Abraham came to mourn for Sarah and
to weep for her.
Well,
I don't exactly know what to do now
because of that.
I'll review what we've,
what we've covered,
and then I'll bring this to a close.
We can have some more questions than
would be usual tonight.
So what have we established by this
point?
The stories that have been revealed so
far or something like that contain the
idea that there's something divine
that's a now I guess to the human
capacity for communication and
attention.
That's APP the,
that operates at the genesis of being
itself.
That's the initial account in the Old
Testament.
It's an account that places the role of
spirit centrally in the,
in the nature of being.
I'm not exactly sure what to make of
that because in some ways I miss
materialistically oriented as modern
people typically are,
but the stories make sense to me in many
ways.
The idea that there's something world
creating about human consciousness and
that that's a canned in some sense to
the divine force that called order out
of
chaos at the beginning of time seems to
me to be a very powerful metaphysical
idea and it also seems to me to be an
idea that is immovable.
He out the foundation of Western culture
because our entire legal system,
our society,
our expect,
mutual expectations,
all of that are conditioned to the final
degree by our presupposition that each
of us has an intrinsic value that
transcends the local conditions of our
being and it's with that presupposition
that we've been able to establish the
society that functions as a society that
functions and functions well and it has
its current characterization and that's
a non.
It's an unlikely occurrence and it's a
nontrivial reality and I don't see any
way out of that.
We out of that conclusion,
I don't see anything that that can
easily be replaced with and so god calls
being into order,
into being out of chaos at the beginning
of time and attributes to human beings
the same essential capacity,
and we turn to Adam and eve in the
garden and they're unconscious by all
appearances,
allied tightly with God but unconscious.
They don't seem aware of the future.
They don't seem aware of themselves.
They don't seem aware of their own
vulnerability.
They make the fatal error of having
their eyes open.
They discover their own vulnerability.
They also discovered their capacity for
evil.
We reviewed that to some degree.
What's the association?
Because it's the tree of the knowledge
of good and evil,
the fruit of which they eat.
What's the association between the
discovery of vulnerability and the
emergence of moral knowledge?
It's something like as far as I can
tell,
that you actually don't know how to be
evil or to be good until you're actually
aware of consciously have your own
vulnerability because the essence of
evil is the exploitation of
vulnerability.
Perhaps for the sake of that
exploitation and I can't understand how
to hurt someone until I know exactly how
I can be hurt myself and I can't
understand how I can be hurt myself
until I become cognizant of my mortal
limitations too,
until I understand what brings me pain,
until I understand the suffering that
goes along with my mortal limitations,
my,
my inevitable death and the suffering
that goes along with that and with the,
with the accrual of the knowledge of
mortality and good and evil.
Adam and Eve were cast out of paradise
and history begins and that seems right
to me because I don't think that history
didn't begin before.
Human beings became self conscious,
so there's something about that.
That's right,
because history doesn't really begin
until people become aware of the future.
Pe history doesn't really begin until
people work and start to build,
right?
We still live.
We would still be ensconced in
essentially an animal existence until
we're aware of the future and start to
buttress herself against it.
Start to wear clothing,
start to build buildings,
start to make cities all in all in
consequence of having become aware of
the fact that we're fragile and that the
future is a dangerous place,
so that seems to me to be existentially
correct and then we have the story of
Cain and Abel Brilliantly placed
immediately afterwards,
and so those are the two first two
people in history essentially,
and they make sacrifices,
so that goes along with the idea of the
discovery work,
the necessity of work and the discovery
of the future,
and then exactly what you'd expect would
happen.
One
segment of mankind,
let's say makes the sacrifices properly
and prevails in the other segment,
makes the sacrifice is improperly and
fails,
and that's perfectly reasonable given
what you see around you because that's
what seems to happen all the time.
And then more interestingly,
I would say the sacrificial failure
produces embitterment right?
And that embitterment produces a hatred
for being and the desire for revenge and
that seems perfectly appropriate.
When I look at people who are bitter and
who want revenge,
it's generally because they're
sacrificial efforts have failed.
Now I'm loath to say that that's a
matter of their own doing,
although sometimes it clearly is the
embittered and vengeful complained to
God.
Blame him for the structure of
existence.
You know,
I read about the columbine massacre and
the kids who
undertook it.
That'll make your hair stand on end.
If you want to read something that will
really disturb you,
a reading Eric Harris,
his writings will really disturb you.
No matter how much you know about human
beings reading Eric Harris's writings
will disturb you,
and Harris has cane you know,
he says it straightforwardly.
Hates human beings,
hates being itself.
He would destroy everything if it was
within his power to do that,
and of course him and his colleague were
motivated to produce far more carnage
than they manage that day.
What was successful was only a fraction
of what they had planned and and Harris
said very straightforwardly that he was,
that he had set himself up as the judge
of being in that it lacked all utility
in his eyes.
Human beings certainly should all be,
should all be removed from the face of
existence because of their pathology.
And the fundamental horrors of being
itself.
So there's nothing in the Cain and Abel
story that isn't real.
It's real.
And cain complaints to God as people
will when they're dreams are dashed.
And that goes for people who don't
believe in God too.
It doesn't really matter.
You know?
It's harder,
I suppose if you're atheistic,
to figure out who to blame,
but that doesn't mean that the
sentiment,
it doesn't mean that the sentiment is
any different,
right?
The same drama is being enacted.
You shake your fist at the structure of
being rather than that God himself,
but it doesn't make any difference
except in the details.
So God responds to Kate and tells him
that he's got no right to judge being
before he gets his sacrificial house in
order.
And even worse,
he says that Kane is the architect of
his own downfall and the invited
catastrophe in his own into his own
house willingly and entered into a
creative union with it and therefore
brought about his own demise.
And it's that additional self knowledge
and you can imagine to,
you know,
imagine that you're in,
you're facing your life,
you're facing the failures of your life,
and let's say that you've had a failed
life and you're bitter about that,
and then you meditate upon it and you
think,
why has this come about?
And then you think,
well,
perhaps I did something wrong.
You know,
when Aleksandr Solzhenitsyn wrote the
Gulag archipelago,
which is the book that detailed the
catastrophes of the Soviet Union and
help bring it down here,
this one part of that book that just
struck me so,
so viciously when I read it,
he,
he was in the car,
in the Gulag and he was there for a very
long time and he said that he observed a
variety of people in the camps who he
really admired.
They were rare.
They were usually religious believers in
his,
in his experience who were not
participating in the pathology of the
camps at all.
Period.
No matter what he said,
he learned a lot from watching those
people.
He had a hard time believing that they
even existed,
that they could even exist.
But he said that one of the things that
he was brought to as a consequence of
watching those people live their
contract with goodness out,
even under the most horrifying of
conditions,
was that it was possible that he himself
was responsible for his position in the
camp.
Now it's a very dangerous line of
argumentation because who wants to be
the one who blames the victim for the
catastrophe.
You know,
you have to be very careful when you
walk down that road.
But Solzhenitsyn was speaking about
himself and he said,
well,
he was a communist,
you know,
and he arrogantly and forthrightly move
the movement out into the world and had
not fully gone over his life with a fine
tooth comb to find out what mistakes he
had made that brought him so low.
But his contention eventually that part
of the reason that he ended up where he
ended up was because he and many others
had completely forfeited their
relationship with the truth and it
allowed their society do degenerate into
deceit and tyrannical catastrophe
without mounting sufficient opposition.
And so he decided when he was in the
camps to straightened himself out bit by
bit,
and that culminated in the production of
the Gulag archipelago and that book
really demolished once and for all any
moral credibility that the communist
totalitarian systems had left.
And so one man in the depths of
catastrophe who determined through good
example,
at least in part to stop lying,
produced a book eventually the
demolished the foundation of the very
system that had imprisoned him.
And that is really worth thinking about
now.
That's one example of the absolute
grandeur of the human soul and the
capacity for transformation that it has
when let loose properly on the world.
So let's say you're conceptualizing your
own failure,
you know,
and you meditated on it and you come to
the conclusion that God forced came to,
Hey,
not only have things not been going very
well for you,
but it's actually your fault.
And not only that,
you brought it on yourself and not only
that,
you knew it all the time.
Well then you might think you'll wake up
and fly,
right?
Right.
You'll get your wings in order and fly,
right,
but there's no reason to assume that at
all and that's not what happens to Cain.
That just makes him more bitter.
Right.
And you can understand that if you think
about it just for a second,
it's like bad enough when something
horrible happens to you,
but then to have to swallow the
additional pill,
right path to take in the information
that you could have done something
different.
It was avoidable and you knew it at the
time and you decided to do it anyways.
And I think people are in that situation
a lot more often than every.
Anyone is willing to admit,
you know,
you have that little voice in the back
of your head that says don't do it.
And you override it and you know,
it's arrogance that makes you override
it.
It's always arrogance.
You know,
it always warns you.
It's always arrogance.
Yeah.
I can get away with it.
It's like,
no,
you can't.
I don't think you ever get away with
anything.
So in maybe your experience has taught
you different,
but my suspicions are,
it hasn't.
And if you think it has,
well,
the other shoe hasn't yet dropped.
So cane doesn't take the opportunity to
let God's wisdom reorient his character
and that that could have been outcome.
He could have gone down on his knees so
to speak,
and said,
oh my,
Oh my God,
I've been wrong all along.
I'd been living in properly.
I'd been making the wrong sacrifices,
able deserves everything he has.
I got exactly what was coming to me,
you know,
could I possibly now straighten myself
out and,
and,
and live repentance and improve my
position.
But that's not what he did at all.
He said,
all right,
fair enough.
I get it.
It's like I'm going to go after the
thing I most admire and I'm going to
destroy it and I'm going to do that
despite its cost to me and I'm going to
do that just to spite the creator of
being.
That's exactly what Harris did at
Columbine.
It's exactly what he says.
In fact,
in his uncanny writings,
it's why the mass murders always shoot
themselves afterwards.
Not before,
because you might wonder if you're so
upset with the structure of being why
you don't just commit suicide in your
basement.
Why do you have to go out and mass
murder before you top it off with a gun
to your forehead?
Well,
you don't make the point is effectively
if you just commit suicide in your
basement.
It's like live my life means nothing to
me but neither does anyone else's and
neither does the structure of being
itself and I'll take all my revenge as
much as I possibly can.
And then just to show you how little I
care,
I'll cap myself off at the end and I
would say also people say all the time,
I don't understand how that could happen
is like I don't believe that.
I think an hour of thought of real
thought,
real thought about your darkest feelings
about existence itself illuminates the
pathway to that sort of behavior quite
clearly.
And I think if you.
I mean I might be wrong.
I might be a darker person than most and
it's certainly okay.
Okay.
Well,
at least I think there are plenty of
people out there who are sufficiently
dark to knew exactly what I mean,
what I'm saying,
these things,
and I would also say that if it doesn't
leap,
do your understanding how that pathway
might be illuminated.
Then you need to know a lot more about
yourself than you actually know now
because it's whatever you might say
about someone like Eric Harris.
He was a human being too.
You know there's this idea in the New
Testament that Christ was he who took
the sins of the world onto himself.
It's a very complicated idea,
but part of it,
part of it,
part of it is associated with the idea
that he met the devil in the desert as
well.
To take the sins of mankind onto
yourself is to understand that within
you dwells exactly the same spirit that
commit the atrocities at columbine or
that ran the camps at Auschwitz and to
actually understand that that's part and
parcel of your makeup and then to take
responsibility for it.
And I think that in the aftermath of the
terrible 20th century,
that's what we're left with.
We're left with the necessity to take
responsibility for the most terrible
aspects of ourselves and that way
perhaps we can stop those terrible
things from happening again.
That's all.
Thank
it.
Also means you know that you don't look
for the.
You don't look for the,
what would you call it,
the purveyor of malevolence outside
yourself,
right?
It isn't someone else,
even though sometimes it's someone else,
you know,
you know what I mean?
It's like there are identifiable
perpetrators,
but that's not precisely the point.
The point is something more like that.
The proper place for the encapsulation
of that malevolence,
at least the proper place to start is
within the confines of your own
existence and then perhaps within the
confines of your family and that way
you're not a danger to those that you
misapprehend as malevolent and evil
because you won't get your aim right to
begin with.
You'll identify them improperly and
you'll take your revenge in a manner
that allows you to admit your own
responsibility,
to act out your unconscious desire for
revenge and to move the world just that
much closer to hail.
Well,
so cain killed Abel and then cain gives
rise to his descendants,
one of whom is the person who's the
first artificer in weapons of war and
then comes the flood.
Right?
Which seems perfectly miraculously
reasonable to me because what those
stories do,
it's so amazing that the story of Cain
and Abel segues into the story of the
flood because it is the case that the
catastrophes that be set society can
best be conceptualized as the spread of
individual pathology into the social
world and the and the.
What would you call the,
the magnification of that pathology to
the point where everything comes apart
and I truly believe that if you
familiarize yourself with the last
hundred years of history,
that that's the conclusion that you
would derive and the people who are most
wise that I've read who commented on
that say the same thing over and over,
which is the.
The key to the prevention of the horrors
of Auschwitz and the Gulag in the future
is the reconstruction of the individual
soul at the level of each individual.
And that's a terrible message because it
puts the burden on you.
But it's an amazing message because it
also means that you could be the source
of the process that stops that
catastrophe and malevolence from ever
emerging again.
And you know,
it's hard for me to imagine that you
have anything that could possibly be
better to do with the time that you have
left.
Well then we see noah who walks with God
and whose generations are in order,
right?
Which means that he's entered this
contract with the good,
let's say,
that has the protective function of the
arc.
He's put his together and he can ride
out the worst catastrophe.
And he's actually our ancestor.
Right?
So interesting.
It's that these people who get their act
together properly and make a contract
with the good are constantly presented
as the genuine ancestors of mankind.
And that's a really positive element of
the story as well.
And it's one I believe because,
well,
it hasn't been easy for us to get here.
You know,
we are the descendants of the great
heroes of the past.
And if you took all those heroes and you
and you and you,
and you told their stories and you
distilled their stories into a single
story,
maybe you'd have a story like the story
of knower,
the story of Abraham.
You know the story of the successful,
the story of our forefathers.
You know not the cancer on the planet
that certain people tend to think that
we are.
And so the goal is to be one of the
people like that and there isn't
anything better than can possibly be
done.
In the alternative is something like
hell and so nola rides out the storm and
that's what everyone wants.
Because you want to ride out the storm.
You don't want to be happy because
that'll just happen if it does or if it
doesn't,
but you definitely want to constitute
yourself so that you can ride out the
storm because the storm is always
coming.
And so then you're fortified against the
worst.
And that's what you want.
Because we'll have the best you can
handle,
the worst you have to prepare yourself
for.
And then we see the same thing repeated
in the story of Abraham essentially,
right?
Abraham makes this contract with the
good and constantly renews it.
That's his sacrifice and his worship.
He constantly renews it and he has the
adventures that are sufficiently typical
of the adventures of a human being who's
alive and engaging in the world,
right?
He,
he,
he bumps himself up against all the
horrors of existence,
and yet the story is told in such a
manner that reveals that his primary
ethical commitment to the overarching
good is sufficient to protect him
against the vicissitudes of existence.
Well,
that's an optimistic story.
And as a pessimistic person,
I appreciate an optimistic story that's
believable and there's great demands
placed on Abraham.
It's not as if this just comes to him as
a gift.
He has to be willing to sacrifice
whatever is necessary in order to
maintain that contract.
And so that seems to me to be realistic.
There's no reason to assume that life
isn't so difficult that it actually
demands the best from you,
that it's actually structured in that
manner,
and that if you were willing to reveal
the best in you in response to the
vicissitudes of life,
that you might actually prevail and you
might actually set things straight
around you and
well,
what if that was true?
That would be a remarkable thing and I,
I can't see how it cannot be true,
and I,
I can't see that it's not stamped on the
soul of everyone who's conscious.
I think we all know this perfectly well,
although the stories remind us,
you know,
Plato,
socrates believed.
Then all knowledge was remembering.
You know,
he believed that the soul before birth
had all knowledge and lost it at birth
and then experience reminded the soul of
what it already knew.
And there's something about that that's
really true because you're not just
creature that emerged 30 years ago or 40
years ago.
You're,
you're the inheritor of three and a half
billion years worth of biological
engineering,
right?
You have your nature stamp deeply inside
of you,
far more deeply than we had any of us
realize,
and when you come across these great
stories,
these reminders,
there are a reminder of how to be
properly and they echo in your soul
because the structure's already there.
The external stories are manifestations
of the internal reality and then there
are call to that until her internal
reality to reveal itself.
Well.
Then we come to the end of the abrahamic
stories,
least this section of them with Sarah's
death and Abraham is called upon to make
the supreme sacrifice and interestingly
enough,
because he's willing to make the supreme
sacrifice,
he actually doesn't have to.
And that's an interesting thing as well
because I believe that it's reasonable
from a psychological perspective to
point out that the more willing you are,
for example,
to face eth,
perhaps the less likely it is that
you're going to have to face it at least
in an ignoble manner.
And so with that,
then we'll bring this 12 part series to
a close.
You
know,
I think that applause is for everyone,
and I hate to say that because it sounds
so new age,
but you know,
it,
it really does.
It really does seem to me that this is a
participatory exercise,
you know,
and that and that it would not be
possible for me to go through these
stories without having you here to
listen.
And so and I always think when talking
to a crowd that it's a dialogue.
It's a dialogue.
You sit and you listen and you've all
listened and,
and,
and thank God for that,
you know?
And that gives me a chance to think and
it gives me a chance to watch and it
gives me a chance to interact because
you know,
you're emblematic of,
of humanity at large.
I suppose that's one way of thinking
about it and for me to be able to craft
what I'm saying so that it has an impact
on all of you here also means that I can
simultaneously crafted so that it hasn't
impacted in principle can reach far
beyond this place.
And so,
you know,
I'm hoping that I'm really hoping that
one of the things that can start to
happen with this at least is that we can
put our culture back on.
It's from foundation because it's
something that's desperately needed and
in order to do that we have to
understand both the evil and the
nobility of the human soul.
And that's like,
that's,
that's a fundamental truth,
you know,
and I don't think you can get to the
nobility without a soldier and through
the eval.
I really don't believe that at all.
It's no place for the naive to go,
that's for sure.
But anyways,
I would like to thank you as you thank
me for your close and careful attention
and your support during all of this.
It's been a really a remarkable
experience.
It's certainly sort of developed beyond
my,
my dreams.
So
thank you.
Thank you.
Onto the questions.
Hi Dr Peterson.
It appears to me from this series a and
from the biblical stories themselves,
that the emphasis of the stories is the
utmost importance of the fool for the
maintenance and adaptation of being or
society.
The figure who will lunge headfirst into
uncharted territory,
explicitly aware of the danger and risk
of loss and confronting what cannot be
understood,
but unafraid and with zeal and that the
dangers of ideological possession just
as much or just as much of a concern as
the individuals are unwilling and
perhaps unable to form an opinion and
take a stance one way or another when
confronted with a fork in the road or a
decision that must be made.
You've seen this apathy,
apathy throughout the universities as I
have to in the public schooling system.
My question is,
how can one model being the fool to
plunge into the unknown and publicly
fall on your face in pursuit of learning
in a way that clearly demonstrates the
urgency and utility of the fool?
Well,
there isn't any difference between the
fool when someone who's courageous,
right?
From an architectural perspective,
and I mean Abraham is a fool obviously
when he starts his,
his,
his adventures.
I mean the story lays it out in that
matter.
He's far too old to be leaving home,
for example.
He's a late bloomer,
you know,
and,
and then he has,
he has a lot of catastrophic adventures
along the way and certainly you could
imagine that had you encountered him
when he first encountered the famine in
the land of strangers when he first went
out.
That's the idea that he had a,
he had followed his misguided intuitions
would have been self evident,
but in the abrahamic stories,
there is this call to get out and do
and,
and that's it.
And the thing is,
is that,
you know,
one of the things I've learned to put
it,
to make it concretely is that like,
I've done a lot of different things in
my life and every time I did a new
thing,
I was a fool.
I did it badly.
I was an imposter.
Right?
And,
and,
and because when you first start to do
something,
you don't know what you're doing,
but that's okay.
That's an acceptance of your
vulnerability,
right?
And your ignorance.
That's humility in some sense.
The willingness to be a fool in the
nude,
in the land of strangers.
That's it.
The willingness to be a fool in the land
of strangers and that's an act of
courage because he will also reveal your
vulnerability to the world by stumbling
around,
but as long as you're stumbling forward,
then you're going to move forward.
Now,
how do you do that?
More concretely?
Yeah,
aim at an ideal,
right,
and you aim in an ideal that's beyond
you.
Now maybe you don't aim to begin with,
had an idea that ideal that so beyond
you,
that you're crushed by it magnificence.
You know?
Maybe that's,
that's,
that's too demotivating to move you,
but you could at least conceptualize
yourself as the you.
That you are with fewer of the faults
that you know of and that's a good
start.
And I also think that's associated with
the idea of humility.
Take stock,
figure out how it is that you're not who
you could be,
and then move in that direction and
accept the consequences.
You know you're,
you're going to get slapped a lot,
but maybe with each slap you'll
straighten up a little bit.
Especially if you listen even to the
people who are slapping you because
sometimes they're the ones who can
reveal for you very quickly where it is
that you're weak and insufficient so
that you won't have to be that way in
the future.
So yeah.
Hello?
Hello.
I'm Dr Peterson.
I have no questions for you.
All I ever wanted to do is just stand in
front of you and be able to thank you
for everything you have done.
My pleasure.
Thank you.
Oh,
good morning citizen pietism.
You got a short one?
Yeah,
I do.
I mean a question.
The best question for last for us for
this one's good,
but first I'll break the ice.
People have said so stayed.
No,
no icebreaker.
Do you want me to get right into the
real question?
I want you to get right into the
questions.
So this question is about a hyper
critical thinking.
Yup.
Now everyone knows that critical
thinking is a great thing to develop.
You have to be able to cut,
I guess,
think about your ideas.
If information is presented to you have
to decide if it's legitimate or if
there's some sort of deceit behind it,
but when it's taken to its extreme,
no matter how great or noble somebody
is,
you can always find a in the armor and
try to figure out how they're covering
up something that's not great about
them,
you know,
and you might then discredit everything
they do is just a facade.
Okay.
So let.
So let me stop you there for a sec
because I want to address two of the
issues that you already brought up.
So there's,
there's the issue of hyper crit,
critical thinking partly in relationship
to yourself and partly in relationship
to others.
So I'd like to address the issue with
regards to yourself to begin with.
So there's this idea that Carl Jung
developed,
he extracted it.
I don't know from where,
from some ancient writings that he was
familiar with.
I believe they were Jewish writings.
He said that classically speaking,
traditionally speaking,
God was viewed to rule being with two
hands,
right hand and left hand.
And the right hand was justice and that
was,
you're going to get what's coming to
you,
but the left hand was mercy and the idea
essentially was that the cosmos could
not exist without the proper combination
of justice and mercy.
You should get what's coming to you,
but people are fallible and they make
mistakes.
And so it's reasonable to apply that to
yourself.
You know,
there's an idea that's been developed by
psychologists over the last few decades
that people are basically narcissistic
and that they generally feel that
they're better at most things than other
people don't buy that.
I don't think the experimental evidence
for that is very strong.
And I certainly haven't seen that.
For example,
in my clinical practice where I've seen
that people are generally far harder on
themselves than they are on other
people.
Um,
one example of that,
I've written about this in my new book
too,
is that,
you know,
if you have a pet that's sick and you
take it to the vet and you get
medication,
you're very likely to give the pet the
entire course of medication to go to the
pharmacy to get the prescription filled,
to give the pet the medication to follow
it through.
But if you are the person who has the
problem,
yeah,
you all laugh because you know the
story.
It's like a 30,
you won't even go fill the prescription
and of the remaining two thirds of you,
half of won't,
won't take it to completion.
And you think,
well why are people like that?
And I think it's because they know
themselves.
They have contempt for themselves
because of their flaws and then they
come to despise themselves.
And I think that's a big mistake that's
locked,
that's too much justice and not enough
mercy.
And you know,
young wrote about the biblical
injunction that you should treat your
neighbor as if he were yourself
essentially.
But he talked about that isn't equation,
which was quite interesting.
So because it's often read as something
like you should be nice to people,
which is not what it means at all
because first nice is a very low end
virtue,
but it isn't what it means.
What it means is that you should,
you should treat your neighbor as if he
or she is someone that you wish to
encourage and develop,
but then you should also have exactly
the same attitude towards yourself,
which is sort of in some sense,
regardless of what your opinion is of
yourself.
Critical,
let's say hypercritical even,
which is often the case with people who
are anxious or perhaps we were hyper
conscientious.
You have to put forward to yourself the
same sympathy we could say that you
would extend to someone else that you
cared for.
That's the thing is that you have to
come to treat yourself as if you're
someone that you care for.
And I mean that technically you know,
you detach yourself from yourself and
you think,
okay,
well if I was going to construct a
motive being that was optimal for this
person that I happened to be,
what would that look like?
And that sort of independent of whether
or not you think you deserve it,
it's like maybe you deserve it.
Maybe you don't innocent until proven
guilty.
That's a pretty good policy.
But you should come to lay out a mode of
being for yourself that gives you some
credit,
you know,
when that will also help you in your
dealings with other people.
But it's often very difficult for people
to do that to themselves.
Okay?
So that's the,
that's the first part of that.
Perfect.
So it starts out with this hyper
critical thinking and you talk a lot
about niches,
assertion about the death of God.
But I see it sort of more like a willful
destruction of the,
uh,
the heroic ideal.
And I guess several months ago I had
occasion to look up a definition or
explanation for the Zeitgeists of modern
victimhood or outrage culture.
And I sought in this particular case and
I found.
And this paragraph,
okay,
this has what you call the rhythmic
cadence that just made my hair stand up
on a sense.
And if you could look at it and read
this,
this is better than
the last one.
The image of man that dominates in
modern literature and visual art,
cinema and theater is primarily a group
gloomy image.
The great and the noble are suspect from
the outset.
They must be torn from their pedestal so
that one can see through them.
Morality counts as hypocrisy and joy is
self deception.
Anyone who simply puts trust in the
beautiful and the good is either
inexcusably and ingenuous or acting with
evil intent.
The truly moral attitude is suspicion
and it's greatest.
Success is in exposing criticism of
society is obligatory.
It is impossible to find words,
lord and brutal enough to describe the
dangers that threaten us.
This delight in the negative is not.
However unlimited there exists at the
same time,
an obligation to be optimistic and the
failure to observe this obligation does
not go unpunished.
For example,
anyone who expresses the view that not
everything in the intellectual
development of the modern period has
been correct.
That is necessary in some essential
areas to reflect on this shared wisdom
of the great cultures has chosen to make
the wrong kind of criticism.
He finds himself suddenly construct
confronted with a resolute apologia for
the fundamental of the modern age.
No matter how much delight one may take
indignation,
he is not permitted to call into
question the view that the fundamental
trajectory of historical development is
progress and that the good lies in the
future and nowhere else.
You know,
I thought a lot about nihilism,
let's say and and its justification.
And I think that a very powerful
justification for nihilism can be found
in the mere observation that life is
rife with tragedy and malevolence of
which there is no doubt,
but then I,
I got suspicious of that rationale for
nihilism over the years because a
counter position to it emerged.
And this is something Nietzsche of
course,
concentrated on as well that had more to
do with resentment.
It's like you can imagine negation of
the heroic ideal from despair,
from the despair,
say,
produced by tragedy and by exposure to
malevolence,
but it's also,
it's completely an delightfully
irresponsible to negate the heroic ideal
because it means that you don't have any
responsibility and it seems to me that
if you're nihilistic and prone to
criticize the heroic foundation of let's
say Western culture,
that one of the first questions that you
could ask yourself is what makes you so
sure that you're appropriately cynical,
suspicious,
and critical and not just running away
as fast as you possibly can from every
bit of responsibility that you could
possibly adopt.
And I think that that's a perfectly
reasonable perspective and I think that
that is reflected to some degree in what
the person who wrote this paragraph was
attempting to new guests who it was.
Wrote that.
No,
I can't really know.
I left you a hint on who has it.
Cardinal Ratzinger.
Come on.
All right.
I'm going to take another question.
Well done.
Hm.
Hello.
How are you doing?
Doing good.
Dr Hughes.
And uh,
it's been a pleasure.
Twelve weeks,
12,
12 moments.
Let's say,
okay,
so two weeks ago we talked about your
mischievous suggestion,
I might say,
a to cut the university's funding by 25
percent and how that might've influenced
that sort of language and,
uh,
Andrew Scheer's platform,
right?
And so,
and then you discussed how you're not
exactly sure what your role is in all of
this and,
and that,
uh,
you don't want to be in a war and you
don't want to be using more like
language and,
um,
and I think,
I think what you,
what,
what you want to be doing is,
is you're trying to restore order but
not,
not but not but not have conflict.
And um,
and so I,
so I,
so after the,
after the lecture two weeks ago,
I asked you like a,
maybe I,
maybe I should do some sales work for
your,
a postmodern lexicon website and,
uh,
but I think I've found a better niche
for,
uh,
someone of my temperament to help this
cause.
So,
um,
I think I,
so I go to dalhousie university and
because so many students are dropping
out,
especially men and especially,
um,
at,
uh,
ethnic minorities.
Um,
they've created this team called the
student success team or something or
student success advisors and you've been
extremely,
a incredibly successful crowdfunding,
um,
for your research and a,
uh,
on your patriot.
And I think like how much does it cost
for a single person to do the self
authoring program?
Well,
it's a two for one,
so it's about $15.
Okay.
So,
okay.
So nothing then basically,
but I was thinking that we could somehow
we could incorporate the self authoring
program into this,
into this new advisor committee at Dal's
that students can freak yourself out.
Man do it.
That's what,
that's like.
The data for the future authoring
program is quite clear if students even
do it for an hour before they go to
university,
they have a 30 or 30 percent less chance
of dropping out in the first semester.
So you know,
and,
and it would really be nice to see some
student organizations that were
seriously devoted to facilitating
student success.
You might think that's what student
organizations should do.
In fact,
well,
it seems rather self evident when you
think about it,
but you know,
so I would say like if you're oriented
in that direction,
get out or so it's a fine plan and it's,
I like the emphasis of it because you're
directing yourself towards the
facilitation of individual
accomplishment and you're at least going
to do very little harm that way and
that's a really good start,
man.
You know that's because that's what you
should think about when you're setting
out to make things better.
The first thing you should think is,
I'm not so sure I know what I'm doing,
so why don't I first attempt to do the
least amount of harm possible and by
concentrating on helping someone develop
their own plan and,
and implement that into the future and
encouraging them with regards to
whatever success they would like to find
their way,
there's a pretty low probability that
you're going to act the tearer tyrant
and,
and play a detrimental role.
So good luck.
Cool.
Maybe we can communicate about it.
Thank you.
Yes.
I'm going to send you an email.
Thank you very much.
Hi Dr Peterson
first of these lectures that I've been
here to to,
but I've listened to all of
them on youtube so far.
I'm going to get you close enough.
All right.
That's good.
Yeah.
Um,
and I've been trying to think up a this
question since basically the first
lecture because I'm a seminary student
at an evangelical seminary and uh,
a lot of what you've been saying has
really been resonating in it and it's.
And it's really been fascinating to
listen to a.
and you know,
there's been many people who have been
asking you questions like,
what do you believe about the
resurrection?
Do you believe in God?
Are you a Christian?
And all these sorts of things.
And you know,
I've been listening very closely to all
your answers and have groups of friends
on facebook who are volume following
very closely saying,
oh,
here what Peterson said this time,
maybe he's one of us finally,
or something like that.
But at the same time,
other ways that you explained some of
the stories sound very close to a,
what we call theological liberalism.
You know,
in the 19th century,
the idea that using historical critical
methods of a reading and interpreting
the Bible and understanding Jesus more
as a moral figure than as a literal
historical figure who was a tournament
provide satisfaction for man.
So I tried to figure out what the
question was because I could interpret
what some of your answers were.
So I'm gonna put it into more of a
general way.
Where exactly do you see yourself
differing from traditional Orthodox
Evangelical Christianity and,
and why would you defer their,
a,
given how much you,
you,
you seem to understand the importance of
the biblical stories in the Western
history and western history.
Okay.
Well that's a good.
That's a good question.
Well,
I off obviously I have to answer in a
general way.
I mean,
I think that one of the things that
makes me different is that I take the
idea that things are a 14 billion years
old,
seriously,
you know,
and,
and the idea of evolution seriously.
I mean,
as,
as does the Catholic church by the way.
And so,
but I don't see that as an impediment to
the pursuit that I'm undertaking now.
I don't know how to bridge that gap
precisely,
but I'm not that worried about it.
I mean,
you can't bridge every gap.
It's just not possible.
It would require infinite knowledge.
Okay.
And how.
So that's one major because I'm coming
at this from a scientific.
I really am coming at this from a
scientific perspective,
you know,
like I try to make sure that everything
that I talk about is commensurate with
current scientific knowledge.
Now current scientific knowledge,
no doubt is airing and all sorts of
ways.
Like I think our notion about exactly
how evolution progresses is flawed in
many,
many ways.
And the recent discoveries in the field
of epigenetics,
which show that you can actually
transmit acquired characteristics,
you know,
has really put a whole real serious a
stick in the spokes of the evolutionary
bicycle,
let's say.
But,
but then I also think the question is,
miss asked in some sense because I gave
this lecture series a specific title for
a specific reason.
And the lecture series is the
psychological significance of the
biblical stories.
Now I'm not claiming that my
psychological analysis exhausts the
significance of the biblical stories.
You know,
they,
they have multitudes,
let's say layers of meaning and some of
those layers of metaphysical and some of
them are more specifically religious.
And I'm trying the best I can not to
wander into those domains like I do
because it's impossible to keep yourself
grounded.
You know,
when you're a discursive speaker,
let's say,
or I'm trying to.
What I'm trying to do is the sort of
thing that young did essentially is to
take a look at these old stories and
say,
okay,
well let's look at this from the
perspective of the human psyche and
let's see what the significance can be.
And not to say that's all of the
significance there is.
Who knows what significance there is.
One thing I have learned about the
biblical stories is that no matter how
deep you go into them,
you are not at the bottom.
And so that's been very,
very interesting to me,
and God only knows about the
metaphysical substructure of reality
because human beings certainly don't.
So I don't,
I don't want to claim that what I'm
doing is a religious interpretation,
although you know,
it drifts into that direction.
I want to stay within the purview of my
expertise such as it is,
and to say,
well,
if you look at this psychologically,
here's what you can extract as as
pragmatically existentially and
clinically meaningful.
And the rest of it,
well the rest of it has to be left in a
bance.
And because I don't have the pasty to
investigate claims that go beyond that,
that does not mean that I'm saying that
what I'm doing is reducing these stories
to their psychological significance.
Even though the psyche is a grand thing.
I'm not trying to do that.
It's not reductionistic.
It's a take on it so people can make up
their own minds metaphysically and they
also have to make up their own minds
about how they're going to act.
Which is really the crucial issue as far
as I'm concerned.
So
you bet.
Hi,
I had a question with respect to,
um,
data being presented I believe two weeks
ago.
Sorry,
a question with respect to data that you
presented,
I believe two lectures ago regarding the
use of Psilocybin in treatment of mental
illness.
Yes.
So subsequently I looked up some of the
recently published literature and one of
the studies that have found extremely
striking was one that was published less
than a year ago in the Lancet,
which is a very high impact,
well respected journal.
And what they looked at was a efficacy
in patients with severe treatment
resistant depression.
And what they found is that in 11 out of
12 of the patients,
um,
they showed significant remittance
following just a single dose of the
substance ops three months following the
single dose without additional
devastating.
Um,
so this not only substantiates,
I suppose my own experiences,
but when you read some of the commentary
or review articles surrounding these
types of topics now with respect to
depression,
but things like posttraumatic stress
disorder,
um,
addiction,
they'll unequivocally state that these
types of results are completely
unprecedented in the realm of
psychiatric medicine.
So I was wondering if you could comment
as to whether or not,
uh,
that type of,
I guess rhetoric is overblown and if
not,
um,
do you see these being more mainstream
than your future or suspect that they'll
fall victim to something on wines of
regulatory capture?
No,
I don't.
Well,
I don't think they're overstatements and
I think I know some of the people who
are engaged in this research and they're
actually very conservative people.
Like they're brave people,
but I mean conservative in the best
sense,
you know,
they're not,
they're not timothy leary and I'm not
trying to put down Timothy leary.
I'm really not.
But you know,
some caution would have been a good
thing.
Although,
you know,
when something like when the
psychedelics burst onto the scene,
no one had any idea what to do with
them.
Right.
So,
and,
and we still really don't,
but the new research is being conducted
very,
very carefully,
but it is really remarkable that those
epithets are used.
Are those,
those terms are used to describe the
results because those are the Lancet for
example,
is one of the top end medical journals.
If you don't see grand claims in the
Lancet,
right?
Scientists don't write that way.
They're,
they're trained from the very beginning
to downplay their results,
but they're quite struck by the fact
that these effects occur with single
doses.
Now I,
I think that what we don't know about
psychedelics could fill many,
many,
many thick volumes and they're in.
They're absolutely mysterious in their
function,
purpose,
effect,
consequence,
all of that.
And I've always thought that it was
really appalling that we stopped
investigating them back in the 19
sixties.
Although it's not been that long,
you know,
20 years historically speaking,
it's really nothing but,
um,
and no,
I don't think that there'll be that the
research will be stopped by regulatory
capture because the people who are doing
it now I think learned their lesson from
what happened in the sixties and are
doing it pretty damn carefully.
So we can hope that more results like
this are produced and that their rec
replicable and that perhaps build,
prove helpful with any luck.
Yep.
Hi Dr Peterson.
I've found this lecture series really,
really enthralling and no one explained
that one time for the question.
That's okay,
I'll,
I'll get late.
You get to the question,
but I'm curious like what,
why do you think that is?
Because it's a strange thing to have
happened,
like where it's a lecturer on the Bible
for God Sake,
you know,
it's like,
it's not something you'd go to a venture
capitalist with a business plan for.
So like what,
what,
what is it about it you think that's
been that it's had that effect on you?
Pop asked you a question.
Yes.
Look,
I don't want to.
I don't want to put you on the spot.
If you want to just move to your
question,
that's fine,
but if you have an answer to that,
I would be very interested in knowing
what it is.
Well hmm.
It's re,
it's a thrill to encounter a kind of
means to a metaphysical system that's so
persuasive and potent and I hadn't
really experienced that a whole lot in
my life.
Huh?
That's what universities are supposed to
do for people.
They're not supposed to take people who
are barely hanging together and break
them and make them weak.
They're supposed to equate them with the
heroic,
heroic substructure of the human psyche
so that they can move out into the world
and thrive and it's an absolute crime
that,
that isn't what's happening.
So Hooray for that.
Thank you.
It occurred to me that they kind of
tradition and genre that you are working
in here.
Is that of the sermon now?
Are you comfortable with that
categorization and
we'll see where you go with it.
Well,
that's,
that's the essence of my question.
I mean,
are these sermons and might know.
I don't know.
Sorry.
I love it.
The last night one call you a preacher.
Well,
you can certainly call me.
Why didn't,
you know?
Um,
I think that there,
there,
there's a certain overlap and the
overlap,
but this has been characteristic of my
approach to education.
So right from the beginning,
because I have some rules about what I
lecture,
what about the topics that I lecture
about and the way that I deal with it.
So the first rule is I don't want to
tell you anything that isn't useful.
I'm a pragmatist,
you know,
like I'm an American pragmatists.
That's part of my philosophical
grounding and I believe that knowledge
is tool like and that the proper thing
to do is to to equip people with the
tools to move effectively in the world
and so I want to make sure that if I
offer a story or a fact for that matter,
I also say,
well,
here,
here's why you need to know this fact.
It will actually improve your life or
it'll stop you from wandering into a pit
which is approximately the same thing
and then it will also knowing this will
also make you more effective actor in
the social world and that will improve
the social world.
Right,
and hopefully will improve the
environmental world,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
And so I would say to the degree that
those who produce sermons are concerned
with producing alterations in behavior,
which is our moral alterations.
Say then I share the same territory with
them,
but I wouldn't say that that's something
that should be only relegated to the
domain of the sermon because I believe
that it is the job of the universities.
For example,
especially in the damned humanities,
to ennoble people.
And to enable them to adopt the mantle
of proper citizenship and that we've
forgotten that we've forgotten that or
we're avoiding it or refusing it or
something like that,
you know,
and I think we're using the death of God
as an excuse.
So I think that to the degree that I'm a
preacher,
I'm making an error,
you know,
and also to the degree that I'm
politicized,
I'm making an error.
I,
I'm wondering out of my proper territory
when that's the domain that I meant,
but when I'm attempting to assemble
multiple layers of facts towards a
practical end,
which is what I'm trying to do in the
end,
is the enablement of the individual.
Right?
That's my goal.
Then then I'm in my proper domain.
I'm going to make mistakes,
you know,
I'm going to wander out of my territory
and I try not to do that.
But you know,
it's,
well,
it's part of being a fool.
You're going to make mistakes.
So yeah.
Thanks very much.
No problem.
Thanks for continuing to do all the cool
stuff that makes everyone love you.
That's great.
Not everyone will.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That's a generalization.
There's lots of people that seem not to
love me and I can't blame really.
Anyway.
Yeah.
I'm going to lead into a question here.
So in your book maps book maps of
meaning a,
uh,
you got that quote from,
does he ask you about how humankind,
mankind,
if you give them all the cakes and the
world.
Oh my God.
So yeah,
if you get all my
God is right,
man.
That's one killer quote.
That's from notes from the underground.
A.
Everyone should read that because
everyone's underground and it's a great.
It's a great little journey through
that.
Yeah.
So it's basically,
yeah,
if you give.
If you have the perfect utopia,
I often use this.
If you have the most perfect utopia,
humans will find a way to screw it up.
They'll go out of the.
Yeah,
because we thought we liked,
we liked chaos and the unknown.
You've talked about this.
That's the
thing is,
is that were heroic adventurers,
right?
We're not,
we're not sybarites laying on a beach.
Although when you get the opportunity to
do that,
like make sure you take it,
but that's not what.
That's not,
that's not the proper calling of the
human soul,
right?
We're,
we're out there to conquer chaos and the
unknown and it's in that we find meaning
and that's better than the utopia.
That's what Dostoevsky,
God bless his soul.
Dostoevsky had that he was such a
genius.
He had everything that was wrong with
communism,
figured out even before it started.
Amazing.
Really,
like if you read the possessed or the
devil's,
which I would highly recommend,
although it's a hard book to get into,
it takes about 100 pages to read,
get,
moving.
But Dostoyevsky he talks.
His main character in that novel is a
person who's,
again,
a very powerful person who's completely
possessed by what's essentially the
communist ideology and he's very
effective at moving it forward and
Dostoevsky lays out brilliantly exactly
the catastrophic consequences of that
both personally and socially.
And he did this like 30 years before the
Russian revolution.
It's just,
it's uncanny.
I don't know where the hell that guy was
from.
Must've been his epilepsy,
you know,
so yeah.
I'm glad I got you all excited.
I'm just gonna keep going here.
Basically,
I used to use that,
um,
you know,
it's kind of fleet to,
a lot of that comes from the left wing,
this utopia we're going towards with
the,
with the universal income and it's gonna
be ai and suddenly the whole population
is going to becoming insanely creative
and with no incentive,
but it's not.
Utopia is not there.
It's not like this thing that hasn't
happened yet.
We're in it,
we're in it.
This is the best thing ever.
And like all of humanity,
the Western civilization like,
oh my printing the material sense.
I mean it just toilet paper,
toilet paper just happened.
Anyway,
uh,
that's so serious.
So we have this beautiful thing and
people are,
are,
are trying to take it down at all costs
and now we go into the dark phase of my
life,
into my question here,
which is actually goes into
Charlottesville.
Had you know,
with,
with that,
with the,
with the initial purpose of protecting
the statue.
Was it good thing?
I don't,
I'm not,
I don't know about confederacy except
for the big thing,
but honestly it's a,
it's a slippery,
slippery slope.
And the confused souls who and the bad,
they just darkened soles for sure.
Not Good.
They screwed up big time because the
purpose behind it is so important
because it's going to be fought founding
fathers next.
Anyone who ever contributed anything to
Western civilization as we know it is
already being.
It's already being done.
James Madison High School in the states.
It's getting renamed because some girls
from random,
one student felt unsafe.
And so yeah,
this is a serious issue.
And I wanted like,
I feel like we're really up against the
wall now because now they found they're
Nazis,
man.
The Nazis are flooding the streets now.
So how do we,
how do we possibly,
you know,
kind of save our cakes.
You had to bring it up,
didn't ya?
Well,
having the right degenerate into
identity politics does not seem to be a
part,
a positive solution.
So one of the things I would say is
that,
like I understand why the identity
politics that is being practiced so
assiduously and so devastating,
Lee by the left has been cooptive by the
right.
I understand that.
But then here's what I would say to the
people on the right who are playing that
game.
If you play the game of your enemies and
you win,
you win their game,
you don't win.
That's not victory.
You just become the most successful
exponent of their pathology was.
How was that a good thing?
It's a bad thing.
So what does that leave people as old as
an alternative?
Well,
I don't think that the Caucasians,
let's say,
should revert to being white.
I think that's a bad idea.
It's a dangerous idea and it's coming
fast and I don't like to see that.
I think the whole group identity thing
is seriously pathological.
I think we've made big mistakes in
Canada.
I understand why at least to some degree
in that respect and that large mistakes
are being made all over the western
world where we're making your group
identity the most important thing about
you.
I think that's reprehensible.
I think it's devastating.
I think it's genocidal in its ultimate
expression.
I think it will bring down our
civilization if we pursue it.
We shouldn't be playing that game.
So what's the alternative?
You know,
I've thought for a long time about a
political career really forever since I
was like 12,
really for a long time and I've always
decided against it because it seemed to
me that the proper level of analysis
with regards to the solution of the
problem that we're facing isn't
political.
And that's why I think it's a mistake
when what I'm doing gets politicized
either by me or others.
I think that the way that you deal with
this is to put yourself together.
I really believe that is that because I
think that individual people are far
more powerful.
There's certainly far more evil than
they're willing to consider,
but that's also a sign of their
unbelievable power.
So I think that what you do is you aim
high and put yourself together and stay
the hell away from the idiot logs
because they're hiding.
They're hiding behind a wall.
They're not able to come out and fight
on their own behalf.
And so the way forward through the of
the logical mass,
and that's the lesson of Western
culture,
is to place the individual at the place
of paramount importance and to make the
group identity emerge only when
necessary and secondarily,
if ever.
And so you can do that.
You can do that now.
You can do that tomorrow.
Like you can put your life together.
And again,
as,
as I mentioned to the other young man
who asked the question is,
you won't hurt anyone doing that,
right?
You pick up your goddamn responsibility,
certain yourself out,
fix up your family,
right?
And then you can be a force for good in
the culture.
And if enough people do that,
the ideological mass will just
evaporate.
It'll just disappear.
I think that's the way you show people
the right path forward to is that you
say,
well,
look,
um,
we would like,
we would like it so much.
If you could thrive as an individual,
drop your cult like affiliation,
right?
Step out of the shadows,
the demonic shadows your ideological
possession and step forward as a fully
developed person into the light.
Do it by example.
That's your,
that's your best Batman.
So that's what it looks like to me.
Thank you.
I'm going to take one more question and
then I'm going to.
There is a young man from Kentucky here.
Brian,
it's Brian here.
Okay.
So I'm going to answer one more question
and then I'm going to let you take the
mic.
Okay.
All right.
Good evening,
Dr Peterson.
Good evening everybody.
I also want to thank you first for your
lectures that I've been following on
youtube mainly and to say that they have
been life changing wouldn't be an
overstatement.
Great man.
And I'm one of the crazy people
increasing your views on youtube because
I flew in from Belgium last night to be
here
for me.
Right?
Right
now.
And English is not my first language.
So bear with me.
Um,
I,
I would have many burning questions to
ask you,
but I thought it was fair and necessary
to pick one and it would be this one.
There are concepts that recur in your
lectures,
but this one you only mentioned once in
your early videos on bill 16.
I'm about self esteem.
You said you don't believe in the
existence of self esteem,
the wind to teach children.
They're all special.
You think you boost their confidence,
but the only result is that some get
narcissistic.
The reason why I'm interested in that is
about standing up for yourself and it
is,
and when I tried to,
you know,
do it.
Yep.
I see that I'm rational arguments.
Faith in rationality doesn't get the
best results in negotiations.
That's why you learn how to be
socialized by playing rough and tumble.
It's not an intellectual conversation
that gets you socialized.
So I'm also reading that book is
suggested about a by Steven Hicks
explaining postmodernism because I
wasn't really familiar and I've been
listening to a lot for talking to him
later this week.
So that might be fun and I'm trying to
read with fresh eyes because I've been
indoctrinated by you of course are very
critical and there's one more point that
I have to agree with the postmodernist
and that is the world seems to me as I
observe it,
a place where powers are play.
It's not rationality.
Delete that.
So when I'm in a weak position and I
want to fight back not to get resentful,
I find that it's not a rational argument
that will get me there.
There's something else that I don't do
and that I should be doing it.
I don't know what it is.
Right?
So you see the relationship with self
esteem seems to me that people who think
of themselves start in a better position
in,
in this game.
Okay.
So.
Okay,
great.
Yup.
Alright.
So there's a lot in that question.
So the first thing is,
is there's a problem with the
measurement of self esteem and that
actually matters because self esteem is
a psychological concept,
a scientific concept if you like,
and you have to get the measurement
right and you can predict self esteem
almost perfectly by measuring someone's
extroversion and subtracting from that.
They're negative emotionality or
neuroticism.
So it's actually just a combination of
big five traits.
And so people who are extroverted,
who feel a lot of positive emotion and
who are and who don't feel a lot of
negative emotion score high on scales of
self esteem.
Okay.
So conceptually it's a nonstarter
because you're not going to move
people's levels of neuroticism,
let's say,
by trying to get them to feel good about
themselves.
Okay?
Now having said that,
that doesn't mean that you shouldn't
encourage people.
Right now,
there's this psychologist named Jerome
Kagan who's quite a great psychologist,
developmental psychologist.
I think he's an emeritus at Harvard,
at the,
at the moment he studied temperamentally
inhibited children.
Uh,
you can.
So they are basically kids who are high
in neuroticism,
probably low in extroversion.
And he found that if those children,
you can identify them as early as six
months,
right?
It's very,
very inculcated in their temperament.
Um,
he found that if you encouraged them in
the world,
you could shift them into a more stable
personality configuration.
And what you basically did was when they
were manifesting signs of distress,
instead of encouraging them to withdraw
and retreat,
which is what they might be attempting
to do,
you encourage them to go out and
explore.
So for example,
if you have a temperamentally inhibited
Charles and you go to a playground and
there's kids out there,
like if you have an extroverted,
emotionally stable kid,
three years old,
as you put them on the ground,
their feet are already moving,
right?
Like a puppy over water and you let them
go and they just run to the,
to the kits and they're there and then
you have to drag them away.
But if you ever temperamentally
inhibited child,
the child will sort of stand around your
legs and sort of peek out and then what
you do is wait it out,
let them watch,
encourage them to move a little bit
forward and encourage them to take their
steps out into the unknown and the
strange land.
And don't let them withdraw like you can
do it.
You have.
They're slower to warm up,
they'll warm up,
they'll habituate,
and if you continually expose you're
inhibited child to the things that make
them anxious in measured doses,
then you can transform their
psychophysiological temperament.
Now you're probably not going to shift
them way the hell out onto the
extroverted,
emotionally stable land,
but you can make a big difference that's
very different than making them feel
good about themselves,
which is such a need to curse.
You need to curse when you discuss that
concept.
Right?
So it isn't the improved their self
esteem,
it isn't how you feel about yourself,
right?
It's how you act effectively in the
world and how you're trained to do that.
So.
Okay.
Now then you were talking about
negotiation,
right?
And you said,
well don't.
You said something like,
don't people who feel good about
themselves aren't they able to negotiate
better and it's.
I know that's a poor paraphrase,
excuse me,
but I'm in negotiations actually a
practical issue to some degree,
like the first thing is that you have to
figure out what you want because you
were saying,
well,
it's not merely rational.
It's like,
yeah,
that's for sure.
You have to bargain from a position of
authority.
Let's say not power.
Authority is a better word,
but you don't have authority unless you
know what you're talking about and
unless you can bring some.
Unless you can bring some,
let's say force.
It's not,
that's not the right word.
You can negotiate without anyone unless
you can say no and you can't say no
unless you've set yourself up with
alternatives.
So when you go to your boss and you
negotiate for a raise,
you need to have the sort of CV that
enables you to go find another job and
you have to have your cv prepared and
you have to have looked for another job
and you have to be able to get one
because then you can go in there and
say,
I'm.
I'm not as productive as I could be at
my current level of remuneration.
It's not reflective of what I'm able to
do and a,
I want this and this is what will happen
if you give me this.
This will be the good things that will
happen and what do you think of that?
And the person is going to know.
Even by the way that you hold yourself
while you're having the discussion,
whether or not you're someone with
options and you can't fake that while
you can,
but it's not helpful like it just
doesn't work for very many iterations.
You have to.
It's it's.
It's not rational.
You're preparing yourself for battle.
That's what you're doing and you can't
be weak when you prefer it.
Prepare yourself for battle because if
the person says,
no,
I'm not giving you a raise,
which is exactly what they should say
because what are they going
to do?
Just like sprinkled the money around.
You need to be able to say,
okay,
then there will be consequences that you
don't like and that's what it means to
say no to someone.
No means if you continue to push this,
things will happen that you don't like.
Now in that case,
it will be all depart and take my
talents with me and if they don't care
well then you're in the wrong business
or you don't have any talents to begin
with.
Right?
Which is so in order to negotiate
properly,
and this is more difficult for people
who are agreeable,
for example,
because there tend to be more conflict
averse.
You have to put yourself in a position
where you can,
you can push back as hard as you're
going to be pushed on,
and that means you have to open your.
You have to open up your space of
available options because otherwise the
person says no,
and that's it.
You're done.
While you'll lose them.
It's,
it's as straightforward as that.
Now with regards to the self esteem part
is practice on small things because you
build the skills.
Forget about the self esteem.
It isn't about being confident or
feeling confident or any of that.
It's about knowing bloody well how to
negotiate.
Start with small things you know,
so you'll notice that there are things
in your relationships in particular that
aren't the way you want them to be and
that you could see how could be
improved.
It's like figuring out how they can be
Negotiate with your partner,
make the incremental improvement.
Keep doing that.
You'll get better and better at it and
then you'll be able to go out and have a
harder negotiation in the world.
So it's a set of skills.
There's an attitude behind it,
you know,
and it's easier for some people than
others.
But fundamentally it's a set of skills.
No problem.
All right,
so now we have something interesting and
unexpected to close this off with.
The floor is yours.
Uh,
Dr Peterson,
I'd like to say thank you for making
your videos available online.
They've had a great effect on me over
the last year.
Actually found them a few years ago,
but sometime around July or August of
last year,
I got hooked.
I would wake up at like 5:00
AM in the morning to watch your maps of
meaning releases the new ones,
the old ones,
et,
etc.
Um,
I found myself inspired by both the
academic and technicals a material as
well as what I might term the more
fatherly directives or wisdom.
I shared this with my family and my
friends as well as my girlfriend.
She's here tonight as well.
She's been following the biblical
series.
BUt what I'd like to say is,
thank you for inspiring me to stand up
and face something that I've been afraid
of all my adult life.
And thank you for granting me the
permission to ask this question here.
It's actually for my girlfriend.
Will you please stand up?
So some might say,
gIven that we are a couple of primates
full of snakes,
it's pretty miraculous that we haven't
killed each other,
but I think you're pretty great and
we've been talking about commitment and
I think I'm ready.
I know I'm ready to commit to a life
with you.
Have sorting ourselves out.
I'd like to clean some rooms with you.
Thank you.
And even as scary as the shackles of
marriage have been made to seem to us,
um,
I'm thinking about forever and simply in
my,
in my words,
I love you dearly.
You feel like home.
I never want to lose that.
Will you marry me?
And if you want to come here,
thank you.
Thank you.
So you're seeing,
you're going to shackle yourself to me.
I'd never run away then I shall suffer
the rest of my life with you.
Thank you.